I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi. We are very excited today because today we are breaking down the fabulous. fabulous musical movie, Greece, too. I had no idea what I was in for. But before we get into it, I think I need a wardrobe change. Well, maybe I need a wardrobe change too. Oh, no. I did something. Okay, let's see what you did. Did you go Co-Rider? I went T-birds. Oh, you went T-birds. Okay, Jenna has on a black leather jacket. She's gone on a black scarf, neck scarf. You got to get that collar up, lady. I got my black leather jacket and my white shirt.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0。你好。嗨。我们今天非常兴奋，因为我们要解析这部精彩绝伦的音乐电影——《油脂2》。我完全不知道自己要面对什么。但在开始之前，我想我需要换身行头。嗯，也许我也需要换身行头。哦，不。我做了点什么。好吧，看看你做了什么。你走的是“副驾驶”路线吗？我走的是“雷鸟”路线。哦，你走的是“雷鸟”路线。好吧，珍娜穿了一件黑色皮夹克。她戴了一条黑色围巾，颈巾。你得把领子立起来，女士。我穿上了我的黑色皮夹克和白色衬衫。
my skinny jeans. And I know the T-birds wouldn't wear a neck scarf, but I have a rash on my neck today. So I thought, let's cover it up with a silky neck scarf and just kind of go Lady T-birds. You're right on point because neck scarf is all throughout this movie. One more thing, Jenna. Ready?
还有我的紧身牛仔裤。我知道“雷鸟”不会戴颈巾，但我今天脖子上起了疹子。所以我心想，用丝绸颈巾遮住它，顺便走一下“雷鸟女士”风格。你说得太对了，因为整部电影里到处都是颈巾。还有一件事，珍娜。准备好了吗？
I actually owned this. Don't ask me why. You have like a pink satin jacket. And when? Hello? I tried to do like the little scoopy ponytail. Oh, and the glasses. Oh, yeah. Sunglasses. Also, you wear sunglasses inside in this movie. Yes, ma'am. The only thing we're missing is bubble gum. And cigarettes.
我居然有这个。别问我为什么。你有一件粉色缎面夹克。什么时候？你好？我试着梳了个小马尾。哦，还有眼镜。哦，对。太阳镜。而且，在这部电影里，你在室内也戴太阳镜。是的，女士。我们唯一缺的就是泡泡糖。还有香烟。
And cigarettes. Because guess what, guys? We want to see. O-O-L and R-I-D-E-R. Well, we owe someone a very big thank you. And that person is Nathan B from New Jersey, because when I was in the general mailbox recently, I saw that Nathan wrote this. Please, please do a movie breakdown of Greece too. Oh my goodness, Nathan. We're here for you. We can't wait. So, lady, I can't remember when it was. It was a while ago.
还有香烟。因为猜猜怎么着，伙计们？我们想看。C-O-O-L R-I-D-E-R。好吧，我们欠某人一个非常大的感谢。那个人就是来自新泽西州的内森·B，因为最近我在查看公共邮箱时，看到内森写了这样的话：请，请解析一下《油脂2》。哦，天哪，内森。我们为你而来。我们迫不及待了。所以，女士，我不记得是什么时候了。那是很久以前的事了。
We talked about Greece II on this podcast about how I had seen it and you had not. And I don't even remember this conversation, but it resonated and people started sending us comments and mail like Nathan asking us to watch it. Yeah, it's true. I'd never seen it. I mean, I'd seen clips of, like, the cool writer video, but I had never seen the whole movie. Well, now you have, Ange. I know.
我们在播客里谈论过《油脂2》，关于我看过而你没看过。我甚至不记得这段对话了，但它引起了共鸣，人们开始像内森一样给我们发评论和邮件，要求我们看这部电影。是的，是真的。我从来没看过。我的意思是，我看过像《酷骑士》视频的片段，但我从来没看过整部电影。好吧，现在你看了，安吉。我知道。
And how'd that go for you? I mean, it is a visual feast. That's a good description. I think some of the songs are great. I think some of them are cringy. I don't know. Okay, where were you in the world when you first saw this movie? Lady, I don't remember exactly when I saw it.
你感觉如何？我的意思是，这是一场视觉盛宴。这是一个很好的描述。我觉得有些歌很棒。我觉得有些歌让人尴尬。我不知道。好吧，你第一次看这部电影时在世界的哪个角落？女士，我不记得具体是什么时候看的了。
I don't know if I saw it when it came out or if I saw it later. All I know is that my childhood, my sister and I loved watching Greece, and we loved watching Greece too, and we watched them both on repeat, and we would recreate the dances, and we would do all the songs. We would have my dad get out a step ladder so that we could climb the ladder, like, Stephanie and Cool Rider, yes. Oh, my gosh. You and your sister were kind of like how, like, Isabel and her friends were with Frozen.
我不知道我是刚上映时看的，还是后来才看的。我只知道我的童年里，我和我姐姐非常喜欢看《油脂》，我们也喜欢看《油脂2》，我们一遍又一遍地看，我们模仿里面的舞蹈，我们唱所有的歌。我们会让我爸爸搬出梯子，这样我们就能像斯蒂芬妮和酷骑士那样爬梯子，是的。哦，天哪。你和你姐姐就像伊莎贝尔和她的朋友们对待《冰雪奇缘》那样。
Yes. Although there wasn't a song about reproduction. No. No. Or Greece Lightning in Greece has some, you know, innuendo. At the time when I watched Greece growing up, it went over my head. But I watched Greece too as a 54-year-old woman. And I was like, holy crap, the number of sexual innuendo songs. It's double entendres for 114 minutes, basically. All right, well, let me kick you off with a summary. And then we're going to get into some. Facts and stats. Yeah. Here's your summary. Two years after the events of Greece, we are back at Rydell High. There is a new bunch of pink ladies and tea birds and a new kid in school.
是的。虽然没有关于繁殖的歌。没有。或者《油脂》里的《油脂闪电》有一些，你知道的，影射。小时候看《油脂》时，我没听懂。但我作为一个54岁的女性看《油脂2》时，我心想，天哪，这些带有性暗示的歌也太多了。基本上114分钟全是双关语。好吧，让我先给你做一个总结。然后我们要进入一些事实和数据。是的。这是你的总结。《油脂》事件发生两年后，我们回到了莱德尔高中。这里有一群新的粉红女郎和雷鸟，还有一个学校里的新生。
It's Michael. Michael. Sandy's sweet, straight-laced cousin from England. But when Michael falls for Stephanie, the tough leader of the pink ladies, he quickly learns that She only has eyes for dangerous guys on motorcycles. Oh, yeah. So Michael hatches a secret plan to transform himself into Rydell's mysterious new biker, the cool rider. But Greece is still the word.
是迈克尔。迈克尔。桑迪来自英国的甜美、循规蹈矩的表弟。但当迈克尔爱上粉红女郎的强硬领袖斯蒂芬妮时，他很快发现她眼里只有骑摩托车的危险男人。哦，是的。于是迈克尔制定了一个秘密计划，要把自己变成莱德尔神秘的新骑手，酷骑士。但《油脂》依然是主题。
Grease is the word. Mm-hmm. All right, here's some facts and stats. The runtime of this movie is 114 minutes. It was released on June 11, 1982, the same day as E.T. I read that, and I thought, that's a tough day to come out. I mean, E.T. I know. Wow. Greece was first a musical that debuted in 1971, then a film in 1978, and now we have Greece to three years later in 1982. This movie stars Michelle Pfeiffer and Maxwell Caulfield. They were both basically complete unknowns, except that Maxwell Caulfield was an up-and-coming successful theater actor.
《油脂》是主题。嗯哼。好吧，这里有一些事实和数据。这部电影的时长是114分钟。它于1982年6月11日上映，和《E.T.外星人》是同一天。我读到这个时，心想，那是个很难上映的日子。我的意思是，《E.T.》。我知道。哇。《油脂》最初是一部1971年首演的音乐剧，然后是1978年的电影，现在我们有了三年后的1982年的《油脂2》。这部电影由米歇尔·菲佛和麦克斯韦·考尔菲德主演。他们基本上都是完全的新人，除了麦克斯韦·考尔菲德是一位崭露头角的成功戏剧演员。
guess what this movie did to his career? Some of the interviews made me sad. It's not great, this poor guy. He said it took him years to, like, kind of find his way back. Yeah, it kind of launched Michelle Pfeiffer and it tanked Maxwell Caulfield, but not in the hearts of people who love this movie. No, because people that love Greece, too, it is like a cult classic. We love him.
猜猜这部电影对他的职业生涯做了什么？有些采访让我感到难过。这对他来说不太好，这个可怜的家伙。他说他花了好几年才找到回来的路。是的，它成就了米歇尔·菲佛，却毁了麦克斯韦·考尔菲德，但在热爱这部电影的人心中并非如此。不，因为对于热爱《油脂2》的人来说，它就像一部邪典经典。我们爱他。
Yes, we love him. Yes. And he's fine. He's doing just fine now. He's doing great. But it was a little bit of a rough patch there. after. It was. This movie was written by Ken Finkelman. It was directed and choreographed by Patricia Birch. And this is kind of cool. Patricia Birch was the choreographer for the original musical
是的，我们爱他。是的。他很好。他现在过得很好。他做得很好。但那段时间确实有点艰难。是的。这部电影由肯·芬克尔曼编剧。由帕特里夏·伯奇执导并编舞。这很酷。帕特里夏·伯奇是原版音乐剧的编舞。
Greece and also for the first movie. And this was the first time a female choreographer had become a film directorial debut. It was also her only theatrical film directing credit. I'm I think this was a tough one for her. Yeah. She said that the script wasn't finished by the time they started filming. She had to start a whole movie production with an incomplete script. She didn't even know where scenes were going. Angela, how was this movie received at the box office?
《油脂》也是第一部电影的编舞。这是女性编舞家首次担任电影导演处女作。这也是她唯一的院线电影导演作品。我想这对她来说很难。是的。她说他们开始拍摄时剧本还没写完。她不得不带着不完整的剧本开始整部电影的制作。她甚至不知道场景会怎么发展。安吉拉，这部电影在票房上表现如何？
Well, let's just set the stage for how much pressure this movie was under. First of all, the original Greece had a budget of $6 million. Do you know how much money it made, lady? I don't. Almost 400 million. Oh my gosh, back then. Back then. Three hundred and ninety-six million dollars and change. Wow. Yeah. So now here's Greece, too. People have high expectations. Yeah. Their budget was 11.2 million. More than Greece. Yeah. Where did the money go? I think in costumes. Guess how much it made? I'm afraid to ask. 15.2 million. No. Oh, it only made 4 million more than what it cost? It barely broke even, Lady. 15 million versus 400 million. Wow. That's tough to come back from. Well, you know, Greece, too, was supposed to be the second film in a four-film franchise. That didn't happen. No. I guess the third and fourth film were going to take place in the late 1960s in the counterculture era.
好吧，让我们先看看这部电影承受了多大的压力。首先，原版《油脂》的预算是600万美元。你知道它赚了多少钱吗，女士？我不知道。将近4亿。哦，天哪，在那个年代。在那个年代。3.96亿美元多一点。哇。是的。现在这是《油脂2》。人们期望很高。是的。他们的预算是1120万美元。比《油脂》多。是的。钱去哪了？我想是在服装上。猜猜它赚了多少？我不敢问。1520万美元。不。哦，它只比成本多赚了400万？它几乎没回本，女士。1500万对4亿。哇。这很难翻身。好吧，你知道，《油脂2》本应是四部曲系列中的第二部。但这没发生。不。我想第三部和第四部会发生在20世纪60年代末的反主流文化时代。
It was also going to be a TV series. They had big plans. They did. Well, there was an idea for this movie that didn't happen that I think would have been kind of cool. What's that? This is according to Wikipedia, early plans for Greece, too, had Jeff Conway and Stockard Channing's characters, Kinnechy and Rizzo as the main characters. Oh.
它本打算拍成电视剧。他们有宏大的计划。他们确实有。好吧，这部电影有一个没能实现的构思，我觉得会很酷。是什么？根据维基百科，早期《油脂2》的计划是让杰夫·康威和斯托卡德·钱宁的角色，肯尼基和里佐作为主角。哦。
And this was going to be while they intended summer school. Because they flunked out. I guess. And then it was going to end with the two of them getting married. Okay. Didn't happen. Didn't happen. Would that have been better?
这本该发生在他们上暑期学校的时候。因为他们挂科了。我想是这样。然后结局是他们两个结婚。好吧。没发生。没发生。那样会更好吗？
I don't know. I don't know. Well, now I'm sort of part of the cult following, you know? I love to hear it. Yeah, I just can't see anyone else but Michelle Pfeiffer and Maxwell Culfield now. Yeah. Yeah. Do you want to know what the critics thought of this movie?
我不知道。我不知道。好吧，现在我算是邪典追随者的一部分了，你知道吗？我很高兴听到这个。是的，我现在无法想象除了米歇尔·菲佛和麦克斯韦·考尔菲德之外的任何人。是的。是的。你想知道影评人对这部电影的看法吗？
Oh, no. Well, it has a 37% on Rotten Tomatoes. Okay. And Roger Ebert wrote this little gem, quote, The movie seems assembled off the shelf. He's not wrong. There are no inspired. songs in it. Oh, I disagree. Disagree. The big dance numbers seem to be exercises in crowd
哦，不。好吧，它在烂番茄上只有37%的评分。好吧。罗杰·伊伯特写了这颗小宝石，引用如下：“这部电影看起来像是现成的拼凑品。”他说得没错。里面没有灵感迸发的歌曲。哦，我不同意。不同意。大型舞蹈场面看起来像是人群控制练习。
control. That did make me laugh. There are like literally hundreds of people dancing at all times. And the story is this idiotic. It depends on how long it will take Michelle Pfeiffer to figure out that Caulfield is the guy behind the mask. This movie just recycles grease without the stars, without the energy, without the freshness, and without the grease. Oh, that's brutal. I also, I take issue with one of his criticisms. I'm sorry, the entire Superman franchise is based on everyone not realizing that Clark Kent... With a pair of glasses.
那确实让我笑了。里面随时都有成百上千的人在跳舞。故事也很愚蠢。这取决于米歇尔·菲佛需要多久才能发现考尔菲德就是面具背后的那个人。这部电影只是回收了《油脂》，没有明星，没有活力，没有新鲜感，也没有油脂。哦，太残酷了。我也对他的一个批评有异议。抱歉，整个超人系列都是基于每个人都没认出克拉克·肯特……只是一副眼镜。
Is not Superman. Just because of a pair of glasses, I would say it was, you know, kind of hard to figure out who he was. His helmet is big. It covers most of his whole head and his goggles are enormous. And did you notice he does a faky American accent? That's right. This is way more camouflage than Superman. Way more!
不是超人。仅仅因为一副眼镜，我会说，你知道，很难认出他是谁。他的头盔很大。它覆盖了他整个头的大部分，他的护目镜非常大。你注意到他模仿了美国口音吗？没错。这比超人的伪装多多了。多多了！
Well, they also wanted a catchier title than Greece, too. I'm not sure it would have helped because these two are not great options. Ready? What are they? According to the internet, one was more grease. I don't like that. No. That's making me uncomfortable.
好吧，他们也想要一个比《油脂2》更吸引人的标题。我不确定这是否有帮助，因为这两个选项都不太好。准备好了吗？是什么？根据互联网，一个是《更多油脂》。我不喜欢那个。不。这让我感到不舒服。
No. It gives me the ick. No one wants more grease. The other one was Son of Greece. Oh, that feels like a Monty Python spoof of grease. grease. It doesn't even make sense. Like, I don't get it. Also, because their sun isn't in it. I know. Okay. Okay. Here would be my alt title. What is it? Collar up, cigarettes, and sunglasses. I mean, that's a great tagline. That would have been great on the poster. They should have put you on the
不。这让我感到恶心。没人想要更多油脂。另一个是《油脂之子》。哦，那感觉像是《蒙提·派森》对《油脂》的恶搞。这甚至说不通。我不明白。而且，因为他们的儿子没在里面。我知道。好吧。好吧。这是我的备选标题。是什么？立领、香烟和太阳镜。我的意思是，那是一个很棒的标语。那在海报上会很棒。他们应该把你放在
marketing team. Do you want to know what's on the actual grease two poster? What? The music and feeling go on forever. I like yours way better. Yeah. Mine is spik. It invokes more of the tone of the movie. Yeah. For sure. All right. Well, I think we should go to break. And when we come back, we've got an enormous opening number.
营销团队里。你想知道真正的《油脂2》海报上写了什么吗？什么？音乐和感觉永存。我更喜欢你的。是的。我的更尖锐。它更能体现电影的基调。是的。肯定的。好吧，我想我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，我们有一个巨大的开场曲。
Huge. That's what she said. All right. The movie opens up. It's the early 60s. We have a huge establishing shot of Rydale High School. Principal, Miss McGee and Blanche, the assistant principal, they are walking out and they're going to put up the school. The school flag, it reads Rydell High School, 1961.
巨大。她是这么说的。好吧。电影开场。那是60年代初。我们有一个莱德尔高中的巨大全景镜头。校长麦基女士和副校长布兰奇，她们走出来，准备升起校旗。校旗上写着：莱德尔高中，1961年。
First Day of School. First day of school. And these are flashback characters from original Greece. Yes. Already, I'm happy. The first line of the movie. It's a voiceover by Principal McGee. This is how we're going to kick off this movie.
开学第一天。开学第一天。这些是原版《油脂》里的闪回角色。是的。我已经很高兴了。电影的第一句台词。是麦基校长的画外音。这就是我们要开启这部电影的方式。
I found it interesting. Are you ready? A new school year, Blanche. A new era. If the Russians can put a man in space, Just imagine what our young American minds can do at Rydell. It's amazing. It is a theme throughout the movie is Russia and nuclear...
我觉得很有趣。你准备好了吗？“新学年，布兰奇。一个新时代。如果俄国人能把人送上太空，想象一下我们莱德尔的美国年轻头脑能做什么。”太神奇了。是的，整部电影的主题是俄国和核……
Possible nuclear attacks, shelters, sirens. Yeah. Like you said, these gals are back from the original movie. Eve Arden plays Principal McGee. She is an absolute legend. She was nominated for an Academy Award. She won an Emmy Award. She has two stars on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
可能的核攻击、避难所、警报器。是的。就像你说的，这些女士是从原版电影回来的。伊芙·阿登饰演麦基校长。她绝对是传奇。她曾获得奥斯卡提名。她赢得了艾美奖。她在好莱坞星光大道上有两颗星。
Two! Yes, one for radio and one for TV. She was also a radio personality. Wow. And then Judy Goodman, who plays Blanche, she did a ton of theater. She was a regular comedic guest on the Tonight Show. Yep. And she was on the Mary Tyler Moore show. And she was nominated for an Emmy for Listen to This Category. Best Continuing Performance in a series by a comedian, singer, hostess, dancer, MC announcer, narrator, panelist, or any person who has, essentially plays herself. Is that all etched on the trophy? I don't know. How do they fit that on the plaque? I don't know. I would watch that woman play the xylophone all day long.
两颗！是的，一颗是广播，一颗是电视。她也是一位广播名人。哇。然后是饰演布兰奇的朱迪·古德曼，她演了很多戏剧。她是《今夜秀》的常驻喜剧嘉宾。是的。她还出演了《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》。她还获得了艾美奖提名，听听这个类别：喜剧演员、歌手、主持人、舞者、司仪、叙述者、小组成员或任何本质上扮演自己的人的系列节目中的最佳持续表演。奖杯上刻得下这些吗？我不知道。他们怎么把这些刻在牌匾上？我不知道。我可以整天看那个女人弹木琴。
Lady, I kind of thought that if they remade this movie today, that you and hire would play Miss McGee and Blaine. I want to be played it so badly. I wouldn't be Miss McGee. And what you just swat at me is I continue playing the xylophone. I'll be so flummoxed. Oh. Well, anyway, these two agree, it's going to be a great school year. And just as they agree, you hear the sound of screeching tires and a crash. And we cut to the pink ladies arriving in their pink car. Yeah, they're not good at driving, guys. They screech and come to a halt several times in the movie. But their leader is late. Yeah. Why didn't she ride with them? Why can't they pick her up?
女士，我刚才想，如果他们今天重拍这部电影，你和我会扮演麦基女士和布兰奇。我太想演了。我不会演麦基女士。而你刚才拍打我，我继续弹木琴。我会非常困惑。哦。好吧，无论如何，这两个人同意，这将是伟大的一学年。就在她们同意时，你听到了轮胎刺耳的摩擦声和撞击声。镜头切到粉红女郎开着她们的粉色汽车到达。是的，她们开车技术不好，伙计们。她们在电影里好几次刺耳地停下。但她们的领袖迟到了。是的。为什么她不和她们一起坐车？为什么她们不能去接她？
Maybe she didn't like to ride with them. I don't know. Maybe she doesn't trust their driving. Maybe not. But this is our first glimpse of Michelle Pfeiffer, who was 23 years old when they filmed Greece. And now we're going to have our big opening song and dance number back to school again. The choreography for this number is so impressive. The song is also really catchy.
也许她不喜欢和她们一起坐车。我不知道。也许她不信任她们的驾驶技术。也许吧。但这是我们第一次看到米歇尔·菲佛，她拍摄《油脂2》时才23岁。现在我们要进行大型开场歌舞表演《回到学校》。这段表演的编舞太令人印象深刻了。这首歌也很朗朗上口。
I read that there were 20 main dancers for all the numbers. But then to fill out the whole thing, there were almost 500 cast members. I believe it. It's unreal. I don't know how. you direct something of that scope. I don't know how you dress everybody. This is an amazing feat for the casting crew.
我读到所有表演中有20名主要舞者。但为了填满整个场面，有近500名演员。我相信。这太不真实了。我不知道你怎么导演那种规模的东西。我不知道你怎么给每个人穿衣服。这对演员和剧组来说是一个了不起的壮举。
What asked what her favorite number was from the movie, the director and choreographer, Patricia Birch, said this. I think the opening of Greece, too, is one of the best things anybody's ever done. I managed to do what, a seven-minute, non-stop informational number. That's where you got to know them. I love that opening, yeah. It's a good opening.
当被问及她最喜欢电影里的哪一段表演时，导演兼编舞帕特里夏·伯奇是这么说的。我认为《油脂2》的开场是任何人做过的最好的事情之一。我成功地做到了，什么，七分钟不间断的信息量表演。那是你了解他们的地方。我喜欢那个开场，是的。这是一个很好的开场。
I know it's a good opening. I so agree with her. She is right. The opening of this movie is perfection. It's everything you want in a big musical number. And the song is called Back to School. Let's hear a little bit of it. How catchy is that? It's so great.
我知道这是一个很好的开场。我非常同意她的观点。她是正确的。这部电影的开场是完美的。这是你在大型音乐表演中想要的一切。这首歌叫《回到学校》。让我们听一点。这有多朗朗上口？太棒了。
Well, like Patricia Birch said, during this whole dance number, we're meeting everybody. We're understanding the relationships. Lady, I have to tell you. What? Do you know who our first caller-up moment is? Is it when all of the T-birds arrive? No, it's actually Stephanie. Oh, she puts her collar up.
好吧，就像帕特里夏·伯奇说的，在整个舞蹈表演中，我们认识了每个人。我们理解了人物关系。女士，我必须告诉你。什么？你知道我们的第一个“立领”时刻是谁吗？是所有雷鸟到达的时候吗？不，其实是斯蒂芬妮。哦，她把领子立起来了。
Yes. She's our first collar up. I will be tracking collars and sunglasses, just so you guys know. Well, she has both. She does. And at three minutes, 48 seconds, we meet the T-birds. Here's what you need to be a member. You need a leather jacket that doesn't move with your body, right?
是的。她是我们的第一个立领。我会追踪领子和太阳镜，只是让你们知道。好吧，她两者都有。她确实有。在3分48秒，我们见到了雷鸟。这是你需要成为会员的条件。你需要一件不随身体移动的皮夹克，对吧？
It's so stiff. You need cigarettes, lots of them. You need sunglasses, and you need poofy hair that comes to a point in the middle of your forehead. Yep. You're ready. You got it. Do you want a T-Bird Breakdown? I sure do.
它太硬了。你需要香烟，很多香烟。你需要太阳镜，你需要蓬松的头发，在额头中间形成一个尖。是的。你准备好了。你做到了。你想要一个“雷鸟解析”吗？我当然想要。
Good, because I've got it for you. Adrian Zamede plays Johnny Nogorelli, the leader of the T-birds. He was 27 years old when he shot this movie. And incidentally, he played Danny Zucco in Greece on Broadway. So he actually, like, originated the role of Danny Zuko. Oh, what a full-circle moment for him. I know. That's really cool.
很好，因为我为你准备好了。阿德里安·扎梅德饰演雷鸟领袖约翰尼·诺戈雷利。他拍这部电影时27岁。顺便说一句，他在百老汇的《油脂》中饰演丹尼·祖科。所以他实际上是丹尼·祖科角色的原创者。哦，对他来说真是个圆满的时刻。我知道。这真的很酷。
DiMucci is played by Peter Frenchet. Goose is played by Christopher McDonald. You know him from Thelman-Louise. Happy Gilmore. And Davy is played by Leaf Green. Now we're going to meet Miss Mason, the hot music teacher. She seems to teach a lot of classes. Well, she also teaches English.
迪穆奇由彼得·弗朗切特饰演。古斯由克里斯托弗·麦克唐纳饰演。你从《末路狂花》、《快乐吉尔摩》里认识他。戴维由利夫·格林饰演。现在我们要见见梅森小姐，性感的音乐老师。她似乎教很多课。好吧，她也教英语。
I know. This was, I was like, she also has time to go to Mr. Stewart's classes, apparently. Yes, she doesn't sit in. And she also loves hairspray. She's carrying two cans of hairspray. Two, yes. And she's constantly spraying her hair. So don't get too close to her.
我知道。这，我当时想，她显然还有时间去斯图尔特先生的课。是的，她不坐班。而且她还喜欢发胶。她带着两罐发胶。两罐，是的。她不停地喷头发。所以别离她太近。
You're going to breathe that in. Yes. Miss Mason was played by. Connie Stevens, everyone. Connie Stevens, who once dated Elvis Presley. I read that. I know. Like, for a while, and she loved him.
你会吸进去的。是的。梅森小姐由康妮·史蒂文斯饰演，各位。康妮·史蒂文斯，曾经和埃尔维斯·普雷斯利约会过。我读到过。我知道。就像，有一段时间，她爱他。
Yeah. And then her second husband was once married to Elizabeth Taylor. Eddie Fisher. Her daughter is Jolie Fisher, the actress. This is wild. I know. Also, I do want to note, the T-birds are very flirty with Miss Mason. Oh, yes.
是的。然后她的第二任丈夫曾经娶过伊丽莎白·泰勒。埃迪·费舍尔。她的女儿是女演员朱莉·费舍尔。这太疯狂了。我知道。另外，我确实想指出，雷鸟们对梅森小姐非常调情。哦，是的。
Ms. Mason says, I'd love to see you all in music appreciation. And Johnny, he says, I'd like to see all of you in music appreciation. And Ms. Mason says, you just might. I mean, this is very spicy. Very spicy. They can also see her in English class, which she also teaches, by the way. All right, well, we're going to get to this credit sequence, and this is where we're going to meet Maxwell Caulfield playing Michael. He was 22 years old.
梅森小姐说：“我很乐意在音乐鉴赏课上见到你们所有人。”约翰尼说：“我很乐意在音乐鉴赏课上见到你们所有人。”梅森小姐说：“你可能会的。”我的意思是，这非常火辣。非常火辣。他们也可以在英语课上见到她，顺便说一句，她也教英语。好吧，我们要进入演职员表序列了，我们要在这里见到饰演迈克尔的麦克斯韦·考尔菲德。他22岁。
He gets first billing. Wow. Yeah. I would have thought that if they were sort of like a. equal experience or status in the world of Hollywood, which it seemed like he and Michelle Pfeiffer were. I sort of see this as a little bit more of Stephanie's story. Do you see it as Michael's? I mean, I think it's the two of them, honestly. Yeah, it's a two-hander. It's a two-hander. I did see this very charming interview with Maxwell Culfield. A few cast members also shared
他排在第一位。哇。是的。如果他们在好莱坞世界里有平等的经验或地位，看起来他和米歇尔·菲佛一样，我本以为会这样。我把这更多地看作是斯蒂芬妮的故事。你把它看作是迈克尔的故事吗？我的意思是，我认为是他们两个，老实说。是的，这是双主角。这是双主角。我确实看到了这个非常迷人的麦克斯韦·考尔菲德的采访。几位演员也分享了
how supportive the original cast was of everyone in Greece, too. I love hearing that. They said it was like a family. Like they were like the big brother, big sister, and they were like the little siblings, and that Olivia Newton-John, in particular, hosted a few parties and invited all the cast. Wow. Where to go, Olivia Newton-John? I know. Well, you know, her boyfriend was in the movie.
原版演员对《油脂2》里的每个人有多支持。我喜欢听到这个。他们说就像一家人。就像他们是大哥哥、大姐姐，而他们是小弟弟、小妹妹，特别是奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰举办了几场派对，邀请了所有演员。哇。干得好，奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰。我知道。好吧，你知道，她的男朋友在电影里。
I know. We'll get to it. We'll get to it. All right, we're going to meet Michael. We're going to learn he's Sandy's cousin, and he's going to run into Frenchie. Yes, we love Frenchie. That's a flashback character. Played by D.D. Con.
我知道。我们会讲到的。我们会讲到的。好吧，我们要见见迈克尔。我们要知道他是桑迪的表弟，他会撞见法兰奇。是的，我们爱法兰奇。那是闪回角色。由D.D.康饰演。
Frenchie explains everything that's happened since she left Rydell. We find out she flunked out of beauty school because in tinting class, her hair turned pink, and that now the most important thing in her life is skin care. So she's back at Rydell to get her chemistry and to mix her own cosmetics. This is a lot of information about a character who is going to disappear halfway through the film. She's just got to establish why she's back at high school. I guess. But she probably could have done it in one sentence.
法兰奇解释了她离开莱德尔后发生的一切。我们发现她美容学校挂科了，因为在染色课上，她的头发变成了粉红色，现在她生命中最重要的事情是护肤。所以她回到莱德尔学习化学，调配自己的化妆品。对于一个在电影中途就会消失的角色来说，这信息量太大了。她只是需要确立她为什么回到高中。我想是这样。但她可能一句话就能说完。
Yeah, it's a lot. No judgment. Just. Well, listen, through all of this, we're still dancing. We're still singing. And now we're going to hear the pink ladies pledge, and I thought we should hear it because I love it, and I can't get it out of my head. The pink ladies pledge to act cool, to look cool, and to be cool till death it was part,
是的，太多了。没有评判。只是。好吧，听着，在这一切过程中，我们还在跳舞。我们还在唱歌。现在我们要听粉红女郎的誓言，我觉得我们应该听听，因为我喜欢它，而且我脑子里挥之不去。粉红女郎誓言：表现得酷，看起来酷，酷到死为止，
think pink. Yeah, that's the pink lady's pledge. Do you feel like Victoria's secrets kind of stole the think pink? I think they did. Yeah. I've been thinking about that for days. Yeah, me too. I'm glad you said it.
想粉色。是的，那是粉红女郎的誓言。你觉得维多利亚的秘密是不是偷了“想粉色”？我想他们确实偷了。是的。我这几天一直在想这个。是的，我也是。我很高兴你说了出来。
Well, there it is. It's on record. Here's your Pink Ladies' breakdown. Stephanie Zanoni, leader of the Pink Ladies, played by Michelle Pfeiffer, Paulette Rebchuk, played by Lorna Luffed, Rhonda Ritter, played by Alison Price, Sharon Cooper, played by Maureen Teefe and Dolores Rebchuk, who is Paulette's little sister, played by Pamela Adlon. And now we're going to see the coach, played by Sid Caesar,
好吧，记录在案了。这是你的“粉红女郎解析”。斯蒂芬妮·扎诺尼，粉红女郎领袖，由米歇尔·菲佛饰演；波莱特·雷布丘克，由洛娜·拉夫特饰演；朗达·里特，由艾莉森·普莱斯饰演；莎伦·库珀，由莫琳·蒂夫饰演；多洛雷斯·雷布丘克，她是波莱特的妹妹，由帕梅拉·阿德隆饰演。现在我们要见见教练，由西德·凯撒饰演，
another returning character. Yep, Coach Calhoun. Mm-hmm. There's more dancing. So much dancing. Everyone dances inside. The T-Birds stop to comb their hair, though. That's very important to them.
另一个回归角色。是的，卡尔霍恩教练。嗯哼。还有更多的舞蹈。太多的舞蹈。每个人都在室内跳舞。不过雷鸟们停下来梳头。这对他们来说非常重要。
Yeah. They have to fix their hair a lot. And then this whole thing ends. This is like a moment that is burned in my brain from my childhood. It ends with a guy running across. The lawn. It's just diving through an open window. Yeah.
是的。他们必须经常整理头发。然后这一切就结束了。这就像我童年记忆中烙印的一个时刻。它以一个家伙跑过草坪结束。只是跳进了一扇开着的窗户。是的。高中的。然后以一个重音结束。就像，砰。是的。现在我们已经开场了。
Of the high school. And then that ends on like a downbeat. It's like, boom. Yeah. And now we've opened. open to the movie. Yeah, and there's a cello hanging from the flagpole. A bunch of kids are hanging out the windows. The school is a little wackadoodle. Well, at the lockers, the pink ladies discuss nose jobs. They discuss who JFK would rather be with if it's Jackie O or Marilyn Monroe.
电影开场了。是的，旗杆上挂着一把大提琴。一群孩子挂在窗户上。学校有点疯狂。好吧，在储物柜旁，粉红女郎讨论隆鼻手术。她们讨论如果肯尼迪总统在世，他更愿意和杰基·奥还是玛丽莲·梦露在一起。
Johnny, the head of the T-birds, comes over, and Stephanie has to remind him, it's over, Johnny. Yeah. We're over. Paulette clearly likes Johnny. Nine minutes, 13 seconds. We have another very big collar up. moment, courtesy of Johnny in a stiff leather jacket. That's great. Lewis is going to come over and give Sharon a big old smooch at the lockers. I know. Real big kiss.
雷鸟的首领约翰尼走过来，斯蒂芬妮不得不提醒他：“结束了，约翰尼。”是的。我们结束了。波莱特显然喜欢约翰尼。9分13秒。我们有另一个非常大的“立领”时刻，由穿着硬皮夹克的约翰尼贡献。太棒了。刘易斯走过来，在储物柜旁给了莎伦一个大大的吻。我知道。非常大的吻。
These two are on. There's a lot of people kissing in close proximity to other people in this movie. So if you don't like PDA, this movie is a little bit of a cringe fest for you. This is not the high school for you. No. Well, Stephanie starts to go to class, but then she realizes she's wearing jeans. and so she goes to her locker to change into a skirt. Yeah, she's got like these little, like what did they call them?
这两个人正在热恋。这部电影里有很多人在靠近其他人的地方接吻。所以如果你不喜欢公开秀恩爱，这部电影对你来说有点尴尬。这不是适合你的高中。不。好吧，斯蒂芬妮开始去上课，但她意识到她穿着牛仔裤，所以她去储物柜换裙子。是的，她有那种小小的，他们叫什么来着？
Pedal pusher, like leggings, right? Yeah, like little cigarette pants. Cigarette pants. Well, I got to wondering, was this a real thing that girls in the 60s couldn't wear pants to school, even public school? Yeah, I noticed Stephanie looks around and sees all the other girls in skirts and then quickly grabs her skirt. I deep dived it. What was the rule? I found this amazing Reddit thread called Ask Old People.
踏板裤，像紧身裤，对吧？是的，像小香烟裤。香烟裤。好吧，我开始好奇，60年代的女孩不能穿裤子去学校，甚至是公立学校，这真的是真的吗？是的，我注意到斯蒂芬妮环顾四周，看到其他女孩都穿着裙子，然后迅速抓起她的裙子。我深入研究了一下。规则是什么？我找到了这个很棒的Reddit帖子，叫“问老年人”。
Oh. One of the threads was about this very subject, people asking, was it a rule that girls had to wear skirts to school? And according to the old people, the answer is yes. Prior to 1970, girls had to wear dresses or skirts that went down to their knees. One person said the hem of the dress had to touch the floor if you were kneeling. Okay. That's how you knew if it was the right length. girls could not wear pants, jeans, shorts, and also no open-toed shoes.
哦。其中一个帖子就是关于这个主题的，人们问，女孩必须穿裙子去学校是规定吗？根据老年人的说法，答案是肯定的。1970年之前，女孩必须穿连衣裙或裙子，长度要到膝盖。一个人说，如果你跪下，裙子的下摆必须触地。好吧。这就是你如何知道它是否是正确的长度。女孩不能穿裤子、牛仔裤、短裤，也不能穿露趾鞋。
One woman said she had to wear panty hose, quote, in an un-air-conditioned classroom in Texas. And then I found this comment in the thread, and I loved it. This old person said, I graduated from high school in 1970, and it was only during the last few months of that year that I ever wore pants to school. A girl named Nancy just showed up one day in pants. Go, Nancy. And when she got sent to the principal's office, she calmly made her case. At some point, he, of course it was a he, was persuaded. I never knew what she said exactly, but I know she was a smart, even-tempered girl who had an older sister. They were being raised by their dad because their mom had died, which gave them both a sort of gravity. After this conversation with the principal, she went back to class and finished her day, and they made an announcement that girls could now wear pants. Wow. I can't really describe when it impact that event had on all of us, but me in particular.
一个女人说她必须穿连裤袜，“在德克萨斯州一间没有空调的教室里。”然后我在帖子里发现了这条评论，我喜欢它。这位老人说：“我1970年高中毕业，直到那年的最后几个月，我才穿过裤子去学校。一个叫南希的女孩有一天穿着裤子出现了。加油，南希。当她被送到校长办公室时，她冷静地陈述了自己的理由。在某个时刻，他，当然是个男的，被说服了。我不知道她具体说了什么，但我知道她是一个聪明、脾气温和的女孩，有一个姐姐。她们由父亲抚养长大，因为母亲去世了，这给了她们一种庄重感。在与校长谈话后，她回到教室完成了她的一天，他们宣布女孩现在可以穿裤子了。”哇。我无法描述那个事件对我们所有人，特别是对我产生了什么影响。
You could ask why. You could make an argument. You could persuade people with power over you to change. That girl was a legend. Wherever you are, Nancy, thanks. That's awesome. Pretty cool. Incidentally, this thread also said that boys had to wear shirts with collars.
你可以问为什么。你可以提出论点。你可以说服那些对你有权力的人去改变。那个女孩是个传奇。无论你在哪里，南希，谢谢。太棒了。很酷。顺便说一句，这个帖子还说男孩必须穿有领子的衬衫。
They had to be tucked in, and their hair couldn't be longer than the tops of their ears, maybe that's why the T-birds put all their hair up so high. And then let it droop down their forehead. Right. There was no rule about forehead hair. They could compensate in the front. They weren't allowed to have facial hair either. Well, now Michael is trying to find a locker and he's chosen one of the T-Birds lockers, and they are going to intimidate him by harmonizing. Yes. They harmonize at him. They do. Well, Stephanie sees all this, and she looks at my and she says, it's okay, it's going to be all right. And now he's done for. He's totally smitten. I mean, he's going to get even more smitten, but he had a lightning bolt moment with her.
它们必须塞进裤子里，头发不能长过耳朵顶部，也许这就是为什么雷鸟把头发梳得那么高。然后让它垂在额头上。对。没有关于额头头发的规定。他们可以在前面补偿。他们也不允许留胡子。好吧，现在迈克尔正试图找一个储物柜，他选了一个雷鸟的储物柜，他们要通过和声来恐吓他。是的。他们对他和声。他们确实这么做了。好吧，斯蒂芬妮看到了这一切，她看着迈克尔，她说：“没关系，一切都会好起来的。”现在他完了。他完全被迷住了。我的意思是，他会变得更加迷恋，但他和她之间有了一次闪电般的时刻。
Yeah, it was immediate. Yeah. Well, now we're in one of Ms. Mason's classrooms, if she is many, or does she use one and she just rotates? I don't know. I don't know. Of course it's her class. It's her class. And we hear over the intercom, Principal McGee, you know, she's making an announcement. Blanche is playing the Zyel xylophone. And she says, listen, everyone, there's lots of extracurriculars, and we want you all to try out for things. And then she says, and we'd like to welcome a new straight-A student, Michael Carrington. And then Ms. Mason has the whole entire class be like, hi, Michael. I had this happen to me. You did? It's horrifying. Yeah. So teachers out there, don't single out the new kid like that. I was new moved from Indonesia to Dallas in the 80s, and the teacher was like, we have a new student today all the way from Indonesia.
是的，那是即时的。是的。好吧，现在我们在梅森小姐的教室里，如果她有很多间，或者她用一间然后轮换？我不知道。我不知道。当然是她的课。这是她的课。我们通过对讲机听到麦基校长，你知道，她在做公告。布兰奇在弹木琴。她说：“听着，大家，有很多课外活动，我们希望你们都去尝试。”然后她说：“我们想欢迎一位新的全A学生，迈克尔·卡林顿。”然后梅森小姐让全班同学说：“嗨，迈克尔。”我经历过这种情况。你经历过？太可怕了。是的。所以老师们，不要那样单独挑出新生。我80年代从印度尼西亚搬到达拉斯，老师说：“我们今天有一位从印度尼西亚来的新学生。”
And everyone was like, who is the freak show? And I was like, hi. Yeah. No, please don't call attention to me. Just let me be the new kid on my own terms. Yeah, I get it. Well, now we're going to go out to the fields. I guess it's track practice.
每个人都像是在说：“这个怪胎是谁？”我当时说：“嗨。”是的。不，请不要引起对我的注意。让我按自己的方式做新生。是的，我明白。好吧，现在我们要去操场了。我想是田径训练。
It's band practice. It's football practice. Yeah. The twin cheerleaders want Michael to play piano for their talent show auditions. So, lady, there's a pretty big wardrobe malfunction that happens during that conversation behind Michael and the cheerleaders. What? In the background? In the background, at around 14 minutes, there are some dudes running on the track and jumping over hurdles. And on the left side of the screen, one of the hurdlers... What happens? His wiener pops up?
是乐队练习。是橄榄球训练。是的。双胞胎啦啦队长想让迈克尔为她们的才艺表演试镜弹钢琴。所以，女士，在那段对话中，迈克尔和啦啦队长身后发生了一个相当大的服装故障。什么？在背景里？在背景里，大约14分钟时，有一些家伙在跑道上跑步并跳过栏杆。在屏幕左侧，其中一个跨栏运动员……发生了什么？他的阴茎露出来了？
No, he doesn't. What are you saying? He quickly tucks it back in. No. Yes. Is this? There's a lot of scuttle butt online about it. People have put it in a, like, a meme, a TikTok.
不，他没有。你在说什么？他迅速把它塞回去了。不。是的。这是？网上有很多关于它的流言蜚语。人们把它做成了模因，一个TikTok。
It's on Twitter. It's all over the place. This poor guy. This poor guy. And I did go and watch to see if it's true. And I, you do see something, find its way out, and then he quickly tucks it back in. Oh, here, Matt just sent us a picture of it. Wait.
它在推特上。到处都是。这个可怜的家伙。这个可怜的家伙。我确实去看了看是不是真的。而且，你确实看到有什么东西跑出来了，然后他迅速把它塞回去了。哦，在这里，马特刚给我们发了一张照片。等等。
Oh, my God. Oh, it's a nut. It's, I think, a little bit of beans and franks, a little bit. It's definitely, it's. Yeah. Definitely the beans. Yeah. Beans are out.
哦，天哪。哦，是一个睾丸。我想，有点像豆子和法兰克福香肠，有点。这绝对是。是的，绝对是豆子。是的，豆子出来了。
I, yes, so, wow. That happened. This poor guy. I know. How did they not see that in the editing? I mean, there's so many continuity errors in this movie. Don't even get me started to, like, who's in the pool, who's out of the pool later on. Okay.
我，是的，所以，哇。发生了。这个可怜的家伙。我知道。他们怎么在剪辑中没看到？我的意思是，这部电影里有太多的连续性错误。别让我开始说谁在泳池里，谁后来又不在泳池里了。好吧。
All right, well, listen, now after he agrees to play piano at the talent auditions, right? Yes. Michael asked Frenchie about Stephanie, but she says you can only date Stephanie if you're a T-bird, and he says, how do you become a T-bird? And then, as if enough isn't happening on this field, a rival biker gang shows up. Yes, led by Leo Belmudo, aka Craterface, played by Dennis Stewart, who is the same guy from Greece that used to bother the T-birds. Right. In Greece, he drove a car, and he was leader of the Scorpions gang. But now in Greece, too, he is the leader of the motorcycle gang called Wait for it.
好吧，听着，现在在他同意在才艺试镜中弹钢琴之后，对吧？是的。迈克尔问法兰奇关于斯蒂芬妮的事，但她说你只有成为雷鸟才能和斯蒂芬妮约会，他说：“你怎么成为雷鸟？”然后，好像操场上发生的事情还不够多，一个敌对的摩托车帮派出现了。是的，由里奥·贝尔穆多领导，也就是“火山口脸”，由丹尼斯·斯图尔特饰演，他就是《油脂》里那个总是打扰雷鸟的家伙。对。在《油脂》里，他开着车，是蝎子帮的头目。但现在在《油脂2》里，他是摩托车帮派的头目，叫……等着瞧。
It's so bad. Cycle Lords. The Cycle Lords. It's not an intimidating name. The Scorpions was a better name, I think. Get out of the way. The Psycholords are coming. Well, the T-birds, they throw their leather jackets on top of their gym shirts.
太糟糕了。周期领主。周期领主。这不是一个吓人的名字。蝎子帮是一个更好的名字，我想。让开。周期领主来了。好吧，雷鸟们把皮夹克扔在运动衫上。
They light a cigarette. Yeah. And they walk over and they're like, we can't rumble with you tonight because tonight we bowl. Yeah. We're bowling tonight. And the cycle lords are like, oh, I guess they're busy bowling. We're not going to fight them now. Yeah.
他们点了一支烟。是的。他们走过去说：“我们今晚不能和你们打架，因为我们今晚要打保龄球。”是的。我们今晚打保龄球。周期领主们说：“哦，我想他们忙着打保龄球。”我们现在不和他们打了。是的。
Respect for the bowling. Yeah. And then Johnny says to Paulette, he wants her to, quote, look special tonight. He's flirting with Paulette. He does this whole thing through this whole movie where he flirts with Paulette and then he flirts with Stephanie. And then he flirts with Stephanie. He full on kisses Paulette in front of Stephanie. And then it's like, Stephanie, why don't you want to be with me?
尊重保龄球。是的。然后约翰尼对波莱特说，他想让她“今晚看起来特别”。他在和波莱特调情。他在整部电影里都做这件事，他一边和波莱特调情，一边和斯蒂芬妮调情。然后他又和斯蒂芬妮调情。他在斯蒂芬妮面前亲吻波莱特。然后又说：“斯蒂芬妮，你为什么不想和我在一起？”
Like, what? Yeah, this guy's all over the place. All right. Should we go to the bowling alley? because this is the piesta resistance of this film, in my opinion. This is just an amazing moment in cinema. It was also Patricia Birch's second favorite number because the musical number and the dancing are, again, phenomenal. The song is called Score Tonight.
就像，什么？是的，这家伙到处乱搞。好吧。我们应该去保龄球馆吗？因为在我看来，这是这部电影的压轴戏。这只是电影中一个惊人的时刻。这也是帕特里夏·伯奇第二喜欢的表演，因为音乐和舞蹈再次非常出色。这首歌叫《今晚得分》。
It's our first real sexual innuendo song. Yes. Because bowling leads to a little in the sack, apparently. The scoring. The scoring. Right. So there's a bunch of students there bowling. There are also some nuns in full habits bowling.
这是我们第一首真正的性暗示歌曲。是的。因为保龄球会导致一点点……你知道的，显然。得分。得分。对。所以有一群学生在那里打保龄球。还有一些穿着全套修女服的修女在打保龄球。
Yes. The nuns are bowling, and they have beef with the team they're bowling against. I zoomed in on their outfits. They like shake their fists at each other. And I'm like, who did the nuns not like? Who are they bowling against? And they're wearing like sort of these brown gingham tops, and they have like this little emblem.
是的。修女们在打保龄球，她们和她们对抗的队伍有矛盾。我放大了她们的服装。她们互相挥舞拳头。我心想，修女们不喜欢谁？她们在和谁打保龄球？她们穿着那种棕色的格子背心，她们有一个小徽章。
It looks like of some kind of Roman helmet. I don't know who they are. Well, they're not getting along. I guess. No. That's amazing. Speaking of these costumes, I would love to give a shout out to the costume department headed by Robert Demora. I cannot imagine dressing this many people for a movie.
看起来像某种罗马头盔。我不知道她们是谁。好吧，她们相处得不好。我想。不。这太神奇了。说到这些服装，我想向由罗伯特·德莫拉领导的服装部门致敬。我无法想象为一部电影给这么多人穿衣服。
I'm going to be highlighting a few costumes throughout. I would say the best dress for this particular number goes to Paulette. A hundred percent, those gold pants. My gosh. She's in the pink gingham personalized button down pink lady blouse with gold trim. and like you said, the most glittery, super, very tight gold pants. Also, the collar up moment goes to Paulette as well, but the sunglasses and side moment goes to Stephanie.
我打算在整个过程中重点介绍几套服装。我想说，这首歌的最佳着装奖非波莱特莫属。百分之百是那条金色裤子。天哪。她穿着粉色格子个性化纽扣粉红女郎衬衫，配有金色饰边，还有你说的，最闪亮、超级、非常紧身的金色裤子。另外，立领时刻也属于波莱特，但太阳镜和侧身时刻属于斯蒂芬妮。
Well, I think we need to hear a little bit of score tonight. Last game coming up, winter take all agreed? But did you shoot the ball? Shoot the ball. Shoot the ball. Knock them down. I'm going to show you how it's done. So fun.
嗯，我觉得今晚我们需要听一点配乐。最后一场比赛即将开始，胜者全拿，同意吗？但你投篮了吗？投篮。投篮。把它们投进去。我要向你展示它是怎么做的。太有趣了。
So that leads into a giant dance break. We are spinning. We are pirouetting. We are high kicking. We are toe touching. Everybody has a bowling ball. They're spinning with their bowling ball. These are clearly faky balls.
这引出了一段巨大的舞蹈间奏。我们在旋转。我们在做脚尖旋转。我们在高踢腿。我们在做脚尖触地。每个人都有一个保龄球。他们拿着保龄球旋转。这些显然是假球。
They weigh nothing. No. People are looking around. No one's even trying to make them look like they weigh anything. They just throw them up above their heads. They spin with them. I think one of the things that makes this song so great are the vocals on Adrian Zemad. I mean, when you hear him singing at the beginning, he's just crushing it.
它们一点重量都没有。不。人们四处张望。甚至没有人试图让它们看起来有重量。他们只是把它们扔过头顶。他们拿着它们旋转。我认为这首歌之所以如此棒，原因之一是阿德里安·泽马德的嗓音。我的意思是，当你听到他在开头唱歌时，他简直唱得太棒了。
Yeah. And also, Lorna Luffed. And I want to play a clip that starts with this high note by Adrian Zemad and leads into Lorna Luf's section of this song. Let's take a look over here. I'm your kingpin, honey, and I'm getting engaged. I mean, am I right? Yeah. The voices on these two.
是的。还有洛娜·拉夫特。我想播放一段剪辑，从阿德里安·泽马德的高音开始，引出洛娜·拉夫特在这首歌中的部分。让我们看看这边。我是你们的头目，亲爱的，我要订婚了。我的意思是，我说得对吗？是的。这两个人的嗓音。
Absolutely amazing. Well, it makes sense because Lorna Lept, this was her theatrical film debut, but she is daughter of Judy Garland. She is the half-sister of Liza Minnelli. It runs in the family, clearly. Yeah. Incidentally, did you know that Cher was originally signed on to play Paulette Rebchuk, but she backed out. She said the salary was too low and they didn't have a finished script. Cher was like, I think I'm going to pass. I think I'm out. Well, Lorna Left crushes it. There is a dance move in this number I need to talk about. Which one is it? There's so many. It's called, I'm annoyed, but I'm still going to dance.
绝对令人惊叹。嗯，这说得通，因为这是洛娜·拉夫特在电影中的首次亮相，但她是朱迪·加兰的女儿。她是丽莎·明尼利的同母异父姐妹。显然，这是家族遗传。顺便问一下，你知道雪儿最初被签下扮演波莱特·雷布丘克，但她退出了吗？她说薪水太低，而且他们没有完成剧本。雪儿当时想，我想我还是算了吧。我想我退出了。嗯，洛娜·拉夫特表现得非常出色。这段表演里有一个舞蹈动作我需要谈谈。是哪一个？有太多了。它叫“我很烦，但我还是要跳舞”。
Okay. Who does it? Stephanie. Oh, yeah. She's so annoyed, you know, but she's like, fine, more dance. Well, I'm going to pout about it. It's pretty amazing. Like, I want to do that dance move.
好的。谁做的？斯蒂芬妮。哦，是的。她很烦，你知道，但她就像，好吧，继续跳舞。嗯，我要为此撅嘴。这太神奇了。就像，我想做那个舞蹈动作。
Also, a lot of people online called bullshit on dancing on the bowling lanes. This is what some folks said. Quote, everybody is dancing at the bowling alley and even dancing on the alleys. The alleys in a bowling alley. are heavily waxed so the bowling balls don't have friction while rolling. Everyone dancing on the alleys would be slipping, sliding, and falling all over the place. Well, I want to offer maybe this is why they can spin so much. They spin with ease. I think they would be bust in their ass. Many people wrote about that. One other thing I'd love to share is that Michelle Pfeiffer said in an interview
此外，网上很多人对在保龄球道上跳舞表示质疑。这就是一些人说的。引用：“每个人都在保龄球馆跳舞，甚至在球道上跳舞。保龄球馆的球道打蜡很厚，这样保龄球滚动时就不会有摩擦力。每个人在球道上跳舞都会滑倒、滑动，摔得四脚朝天。”嗯，我想提出，也许这就是他们能转那么多圈的原因。他们转得很轻松。我觉得他们会摔个底朝天。很多人都写过这个。还有一件事我想分享，那就是米歇尔·菲佛在一次采访中说
that she kept her bowling ball. Oh. From this movie and still has it. Well, outside, Michael is What is happening here, okay? He's got some type of book, like a manual that tells you how to talk to people about bowling. Yeah, I wrote down the suggestions from the book. I did too. Always be courteous when asking for a game. Hi, want a game? Howdy, fellas?
她留下了她的保龄球。哦。来自这部电影，现在还留着。嗯，在外面，迈克尔，这里发生了什么，好吗？他拿着某种书，就像一本手册，告诉你如何与人谈论保龄球。是的，我记下了书中的建议。我也记了。询问比赛时一定要礼貌。嗨，想来一场吗？嘿，伙计们？
Let's bowl some balls. Bowling anyone? What is this book? There were a lot of pages in this book. I have to think that it addresses more than bowling. I hope so. But also, wow, that there's even a section. Well, inside everyone is now done bowling.
让我们打几局球。有人要打保龄球吗？这是什么书？这本书里有很多页。我不得不认为它涉及的不仅仅是保龄球。我希望如此。但也，哇，竟然还有这样一个章节。嗯，在里面，每个人现在都打完保龄球了。
They're walking up to return their shoes. Johnny wants a trophy for winning because they won. Yeah. So Paulette goes over, she gives them a big, long smooch. Yeah. And he's like, that's great. That was the trophy for best average. Then he turns to Stephanie and he says,
他们正走过去归还鞋子。约翰尼想要一个奖杯，因为他们赢了。是的。所以波莱特走过去，给了他们一个又长又大的吻。是的。他说，太棒了。那是最佳平均分奖杯。然后他转向斯蒂芬妮说，
how about a kiss for best score? And Stephanie says, I ain't no one's. trophy. And he says, so that's the way it's going to be now, huh, Miss Independent? And she says, yeah, independent. I kiss who I want, when I want. I could kiss the next guy who walks through that door if I want. And he says, be my guest. Well, guess who walks in right at that moment? Michael. And she lays one on him. He's shocked. Everyone's shocked. Then she walks over to the group, and she says, let's eat. Mm-hmm.
来个吻作为最佳得分奖怎么样？斯蒂芬妮说，我才不是谁的奖杯。他说，所以现在要变成这样了，是吗，独立小姐？她说，是的，独立。我想吻谁就吻谁，想什么时候吻就什么时候吻。如果我想的话，我可以吻下一个走进那扇门的人。他说，请便。嗯，猜猜那一刻谁进来了？迈克尔。她吻了他。他很震惊。每个人都很震惊。然后她走到那群人面前说，我们去吃饭吧。嗯哼。
Wow. This scene, that whole line of, that's the way it's going to be now, huh? Miss Independent. She's like, yeah, independent. My sister and I used to do the dialogue from this scene. That's adorable. Some of my favorite dialogue from the movie.
哇。这一幕，整句“所以现在要变成这样了，是吗，独立小姐？”她就像，是的，独立。我和我姐姐过去常演这一幕的台词。太可爱了。这是我电影中最喜欢的一些台词。
That's so cute, lady. Well, our next big scene is a new day at school. We're going to meet Mr. Stewart. I'm sorry, but before that, we're going to see the pink ladies arrive again without Stephanie. And I just want to say I don't understand. understand why they can't drive Stephanie to school. I don't know. Is that when they almost crash into the tree? Yeah. I don't think she likes to ride with them, lady. Okay, fine. They almost run over Mr.
太可爱了，女士。嗯，我们的下一个大场景是学校新的一天。我们要见斯图尔特先生。抱歉，但在那之前，我们要再次看到粉红女郎们到达，没有斯蒂芬妮。我只想说我不明白为什么她们不能开车送斯蒂芬妮去学校。我不知道。那是她们差点撞到树的时候吗？是的。我觉得她不喜欢和她们一起坐车，女士。好吧，好吧。她们差点撞到斯图尔特先生
Stewart upon arriving. Mr. Stewart very quickly meets Miss Mason, aka Sexy McSexe, and he says he likes her hair. She loves her hair. She's got great hair. Mr. Stewart was played by Tab Hunter. So incidentally, both Connie Stevens and Tab Hunter, they were like, matinee idols when they were younger. So the casting of these two was kind of a nod to the older audience. It reminds me a little bit of us and Lee's movie, Angela. It's a movie about young people and rock and roll. And a few recognizable oldies. Yes, they sprinkle in some matinee idols of the past. And that's me and you. And Fred Armisen and Bobby Lee, I think. Our job in Lee's movie. I would do it all day long. It's super fun to be the old. these on set. And we find out about the big talent show. It's the Rydell Review. Prices are
到达时。斯图尔特先生很快见到了梅森小姐，也就是“性感麦克性感”，他说他喜欢她的头发。她喜欢她的头发。她有一头很棒的头发。斯图尔特先生由塔布·亨特饰演。顺便说一句，康妮·史蒂文斯和塔布·亨特年轻时都是日场偶像。所以这两个人的选角是对老观众的一种致敬。这让我想起了一点我们和李的电影《安吉拉》。这是一部关于年轻人和摇滚乐的电影。还有一些可辨认的老面孔。是的，他们穿插了一些过去的日场偶像。那就是我和你。还有弗雷德·阿米森和鲍比·李，我想。我们在李电影里的工作。我会整天做这件事。在片场做老面孔超级有趣。我们发现了大型才艺表演。那是莱德尔评论。奖品是
100 long playing records. The T-birds really want them. Yeah, they do. Well, now we're going to get to this little bit in the hallway between Johnny and the principal. She's scolding him about riding motorcycles across the school lawn. And the whole time, he's hiding a cigarette in his mouth. Yeah, he's smoking as she walks up and he does the thing where he folds it into his mouth. Yeah, this would drive me crazy. I would have to skip this scene. I don't care for it. I don't care for I don't like it, that then his friend slaps him on the back and he swallows it. This would make my sister and I crazy this scene. Well, I looked up how they did this gag.
100张长篇唱片。雷鸟队真的很想要它们。是的，他们想要。嗯，现在我们要讲到约翰尼和校长之间走廊里的这一小段。她在责骂他骑摩托车穿过学校草坪。而整个过程中，他嘴里藏着一根香烟。是的，她走过来时他在抽烟，他做了那个把它折进嘴里的动作。是的，这会让我发疯。我不得不跳过这一幕。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢，然后他的朋友拍了他的背，他就把它吞下去了。这会让我和我姐姐发疯，这一幕。嗯，我查了一下他们是怎么做这个恶作剧的。
And according to the internet, actor Adrian Zemad confirmed it was a real cigarette, not a special effect. The bit was written into the movie by Ken Finkelman who did this in high school. So Zemad practiced this trick every day for roughly two months before shooting the scene. He did hold the cigarette in his mouth, but he did not swallow it, Jenna. That is crazy to me. I assumed that he did the flip, I believed it, and then I assumed they took it out, and that whole time that he was talking to Miss McGee, he was just pretending to hop up. That makes it even harder for me to watch now, knowing that the cigarette was in his mouth the whole time.
根据互联网，演员阿德里安·泽马德证实那是一根真正的香烟，而不是特效。这个片段是由肯·芬克尔曼写进电影里的，他在高中时就这么做过。所以泽马德在拍摄这一幕之前，每天练习这个技巧大约两个月。他确实把香烟含在嘴里，但他没有吞下去，珍娜。这对我来说太疯狂了。我以为他做了那个翻转，我相信了，然后我以为他们把它拿出来了，在他和麦基小姐说话的整个过程中，他只是假装跳起来。这让我现在看它变得更难了，知道香烟一直在他嘴里。
He did say when the camera came onto his back, he didn't have the cigarette in his mouth anymore. Well, thank God. But when he was facing forward, he did. Wow. Well, let's get to these talent show auditions, lady. First, we have a riveting song about a guy named Brad. by the twins with Michael on piano. So this guy, Brad, was played by Matt Lentanzi.
他确实说过，当摄像机拍到他的背部时，他嘴里已经没有香烟了。嗯，谢天谢地。但当他面向前方时，他确实有。哇。嗯，让我们进入这些才艺表演试镜吧，女士。首先，我们有一首关于一个叫布拉德的家伙的引人入胜的歌，由双胞胎演唱，迈克尔弹钢琴。所以这个叫布拉德的家伙由马特·伦坦齐饰演。
He had a small part in Zanadu the year before where he met Olivia Newton-John. And then he got cast in Greece, too. And this whole time he was Olivia Newton-John's boyfriend. They actually ended up getting married. They had a daughter. They divorced after 11 years of marriage. But maybe this is why she was hosting all those parties. because her boyfriend was in the movie.
他在前一年在《仙纳杜》中有一个小角色，在那里他遇到了奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰。然后他被选中出演《油脂2》。整个过程中，他是奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰的男朋友。他们实际上最终结婚了。他们有一个女儿。结婚11年后离婚了。但也许这就是她举办所有那些派对的原因，因为她的男朋友在电影里。
Yeah. But also, I mean, Lorna Luff said that just the whole cast was so warm to them. I believe it. Well, now we have the pink ladies. They're going to audition. Their song is Calendar Girls. Michael is playing the piano again.
是的。但还有，我的意思是，洛娜·拉夫特说整个剧组对他们都非常热情。我相信。嗯，现在我们有粉红女郎了。她们要试镜。她们的歌是《日历女孩》。迈克尔又在弹钢琴了。
Sharon is clearly running the show. The role of Sharon was originally going to be played by Jennifer Beals, but she left to take the lead role in Flash Dance. Oh. But I think if I was going to be in this movie, Like when I was younger, I would have played Sharon. I love this line that she says to Rhonda. She goes, Rhonda, your fall.
莎伦显然在掌控全局。莎伦这个角色最初打算由詹妮弗·比尔斯扮演，但她离开去出演《闪电舞》的主角了。哦。但我觉得如果我要演这部电影，就像我年轻的时候，我会演莎伦。我喜欢她对朗达说的这句台词。她说，朗达，你的秋天。
Give me maturity. Give me aging. Rhonda's like, give me a break. Who would you have played, lady? Maybe Paulette. I could see you as Paulette. You'd be great. Thanks.
给我成熟。给我衰老。朗达说，饶了我吧。你会演谁，女士？也许是波莱特。我能看出你演波莱特。你会很棒的。谢谢。
Well, the Calendar Girl song, I find it so grating. It's hard for me. I really hate the beginning with the a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a. So I'm going to play a clip. You're playing the song you hate? Yeah, because it's going to lead into a really cringy conversation between Michael and Stephanie. Hi. I wanted to ask you if you're free after school today.
嗯，《日历女孩》这首歌，我觉得太刺耳了。对我来说很难。我真的很讨厌开头那个“啊-啊-啊-啊-啊-啊-啊-啊-啊”。所以我打算播放一段剪辑。你在播放你讨厌的歌？是的，因为它会引出迈克尔和斯蒂芬妮之间一段非常尴尬的对话。嗨。我想问你今天放学后有空吗？
Yeah, I'm free every day. It's in the Constitution. Yeah, that's another line we would always quote. Yeah, I'm free every day. It's in the Constitution. Yeah. The pink ladies get cut off after just one season, and Sharon is really upset. But Michael's going to hit up Stephanie again after the song, but she's too busy to go out.
是的，我每天都有空。宪法里写着呢。是的，那是我们总是引用的另一句台词。是的，我每天都有空。宪法里写着呢。是的。粉红女郎们只唱了一段就被打断了，莎伦真的很生气。但迈克尔在歌唱完后会再次找斯蒂芬妮，但她太忙了，没空出去。
She's very busy. He'd like to know, like, what was up with the bowling alley? And she's like, that was a joke. Okay, get over it. Yeah. Yeah. And then she forgot her book. So he asked her again.
她非常忙。他想知道，保龄球馆是怎么回事？她说，那是个玩笑。好吧，忘掉它吧。是的。是的。然后她忘了她的书。所以他又问了她一次。
He says, how about the day after tomorrow? And she can't take it. And she's going to explain what she's actually looking for in a guy. I think we should hear it. If you really want to know with Helen his eye, I want a devil when fine now, I'll be holding on. Here's the thing. She is so dynamic when she's singing.
他说，后天怎么样？她受不了了。她要解释她到底在找什么样的男人。我想我们应该听听。如果你真的想知道，海伦他的眼睛，我想要一个魔鬼，当好的时候，现在，我会坚持住。事情是这样的。她唱歌时太有活力了。
There's like this spotlight on her. Her eyes are on fire. She has this amazing red lipstick. She's so intense. She's completely captivating. She is. She's wearing all black. She has a black top, black tight pants, black bangle bracelets.
就像有一束聚光灯照在她身上。她的眼睛在燃烧。她涂着这种惊人的红唇膏。她太强烈了。她完全令人着迷。她是。她全身穿黑。她穿着黑色上衣，黑色紧身裤，黑色手镯。
Her pink lady jacket is reversible lady. She's wearing it in black. Oh. But if Michael didn't know. really what she's into, her necklace is a dead giveaway. Why? What is it? It's a gold necklace with a motorcycle pendant. Well, here's the thing. I wrote down, I think this is why she got the part. Holy shit. She's amazing. All during this first section of the song, there were these weird cutaways to Michael listening to her sing, and he's a complete, like, just blank slate. But then
她的粉红女郎夹克是双面的，女士。她穿着黑色那面。哦。但如果迈克尔真的不知道她喜欢什么，她的项链是一个死胡同。为什么？那是什么？那是一条带有摩托车吊坠的金项链。嗯，事情是这样的。我记下来了，我认为这就是她得到这个角色的原因。天哪。她太棒了。在整首歌的第一部分，有一些奇怪的剪辑，迈克尔听着她唱歌，他完全就像一张白纸。但后来
something happens. What? Then she starts dancing. Well, I learned one of her dance moves. I'd like to show it to you now. Oh, God. Please. No, that's the one I can't take at the end. Here's the thing.
发生了什么？然后她开始跳舞。嗯，我学会了她的一个舞蹈动作。我现在想给你展示一下。哦，天哪。求你了。不，那是最后我受不了的那个。事情是这样的。
I have compassion for her because I'm looking at this whole scene through the camera lens, and she's got to cover a lot of ground in a short amount of time. So she does this weird scooching dance move. I don't know how else you cover that amount of ground unless you can do cartwheels and stuff. But I was curious what Michelle Pfeiffer had to say about her audition process. I was curious about her background
我同情她，因为我通过摄像机镜头看着整个场景，她必须在短时间内覆盖很多地面。所以她做了这个奇怪的滑行舞蹈动作。我不知道除了你会做侧手翻之类的东西，你还能怎么覆盖那么大的地面。但我很好奇米歇尔·菲佛对她的试镜过程有什么要说的。我很好奇她的背景
for singing and dancing. And I found this interview of her on the James Corden show. Here's what she had to say. Now, what was your audition process like for Greece too? Well, it was a total fluke that I got that part. And I went on a lark. I mean, my agent said,
关于唱歌和跳舞。我发现了她在詹姆斯·柯登秀上的这次采访。这是她要说的。那么，你出演《油脂2》的试镜过程是怎样的？嗯，我得到那个角色完全是侥幸。我是去碰运气的。我的意思是，我的经纪人说，
oh, just go. I wasn't a dancer. I wasn't a singer. And I was in this little short purple skirt with go-go boots. And we had the dancing auditions. And, you know, it's literally like a chorus line. It's like this line goes. And then the next line goes. And I kept sneaking in the back. And finally, it was only me. Sure. And the director's like, come on, come on. So I go and, you know, go down there. But anyway, I did. And I got. the part and I, you know, shockingly enough. And then we all got given Greece too. And how could we mad about that?
哦，去吧。我不是舞者。我不是歌手。我穿着这条紫色的小短裙，配着高筒靴。我们有舞蹈试镜。而且，你知道，这简直就像合唱队。就像这一行走。然后下一行走。我一直在后面偷偷溜进去。最后，只剩下我了。当然。导演说，来吧，来吧。所以我去了，你知道，到下面去。但无论如何，我做了。我得到了这个角色，我，你知道，令人震惊的是。然后我们都得到了《油脂2》。我们怎么能对此生气呢？
I mean, she was surprised. Well, here's what I wrote down. I wrote, she's so sexy when she's singing. And then she is so not sexy when they make her dance. And I just wrote, let this woman sing. Why did this need to be a dance? number. It was so good. Because later, we're going to let Michael wax on for three minutes about his charade. He doesn't have to dance through that song. His whole ballad that, like, I can't even take.
我的意思是，她很惊讶。嗯，这是我记下来的。我写道，她唱歌时太性感了。然后当他们让她跳舞时，她一点也不性感。我只是写道，让这个女人唱歌吧。为什么这需要成为一个舞蹈表演？它太好了。因为后来，我们要让迈克尔花三分钟时间谈论他的字谜。他不需要在那首歌里跳舞。他整首民谣，就像，我甚至受不了。
It's just a giant montage. Why couldn't she just stand there and sing, like, the powerhouse that she is? And the thing is that, like, when you're seeing her face and her eyes, the singing sounds great, leave her alone. Don't make this woman dance anymore. I would say don't make her do any more. than the ladder. The ladder was very impressive. The ladder is tall. It's got a tiny little top of the ladder that then she had to like kind of move around on. I was terrified for her. And then the way she comes off that ladder is the coolest thing I've ever seen. With her big sweeping leg. I would have wiped out. I would have absolutely face planted. Because she goes down a few, then up a few and then down a few more and then up one. Yes. Just leave her on the ladder.
这只是一个巨大的蒙太奇。为什么她不能就站在那里唱，像她那样的强力歌手？问题是，当你看到她的脸和她的眼睛时，歌声听起来很棒，别管她。别再让这个女人跳舞了。我会说别让她做任何比梯子更多的动作。梯子非常令人印象深刻。梯子很高。梯子顶部有一个很小的部分，然后她不得不像在上面移动一样。我为她感到害怕。然后她从梯子上下来的方式是我见过的最酷的事情。带着她那条大大的扫腿。我会摔倒的。我会绝对脸朝下摔倒的。因为她下几级，然后上几级，然后又下几级，然后又上一级。是的。就让她在梯子上吧。
In fact, you know what you don't make her do when she's on the top of the ladder, which again kills the whole ladder bit, the jazz hands. Why the jazz hands? Why is it? This is not sexy. I'm sorry. Like if you're dancing for your husband and you're being sexy and then you start doing jazz hands, it's gone.
事实上，你知道当她在梯子顶端时你不要让她做什么吗，这又毁了整个梯子片段，爵士手。为什么是爵士手？为什么？这不性感。我很抱歉。就像如果你在为你丈夫跳舞，你很性感，然后你开始做爵士手，它就没了。
Or if he likes jazz hands, maybe there's another conversation to be had. I mean, sure. Maybe you have a thing for jazz hands, but I just think there's, you can't be sexy while doing jazz hands. There's not a single stripper who does jazz hands. I'm convinced. No one's doing it. It's not happening.
或者如果他喜欢爵士手，也许还有另一个对话要进行。我的意思是，当然。也许你对爵士手有某种情结，但我只是认为，你不能在做爵士手的同时保持性感。没有一个脱衣舞娘会做爵士手。我确信。没有人这样做。它不会发生。
I just also think that there's maybe a reason the latter was part of this move because maybe they saw her do the scoge move. And they were like, we need a prop. It was great. Yeah. But it all falls apart when she, oh, God. Anyway, I both, I love cool rider, but the dancing is hard. That's all we have to say about that. I think we should take a break.
我也只是认为，梯子成为这个动作的一部分可能有一个原因，因为也许他们看到她做了那个滑行动作。他们就像，我们需要一个道具。这很棒。是的。但当她，哦，天哪，一切都崩溃了。无论如何，我，我喜欢《酷骑士》，但舞蹈很难。这就是我们要说的全部。我想我们应该休息一下。
and then when we come back. Michael has figured out a way to buy a motorcycle, and it includes selling essays and homework. I break down the math of it. Oh. When we come back. Great. We are back, and like Angela said before the break,
然后当我们回来时。迈克尔想出了一种买摩托车的方法，包括卖论文和家庭作业。我分解了其中的数学。哦。当我们回来时。太棒了。我们回来了，就像安吉拉在休息前说的那样，
the T-birds are going to start asking Michael to do their homework for them. It's a secret. It's a secret. They got a rep to protect. Exactly. They all are very worried about their reps. Yes.
雷鸟队开始要求迈克尔为他们做家庭作业。这是一个秘密。这是一个秘密。他们有名声要保护。正是如此。他们都非常担心他们的名声。是的。
their rep of doing their own homework? I don't know. I don't know. But he's doing it so that he can earn money to buy a motorcycle. Yeah. Louie comes to what we learn is Michael's uncle's nuclear fallout shelter, where I guess Michael hangs out and does his homework? Yeah, I said, does he live in his uncle's fallout shelter or just do his homework in there?
他们自己做家庭作业的名声？我不知道。我不知道。但他这样做是为了赚钱买摩托车。是的。路易来到了我们所了解的迈克尔叔叔的核辐射避难所，我想迈克尔在那里闲逛并做他的家庭作业？是的，我说，他住在叔叔的避难所里，还是只是在里面做家庭作业？
I don't know. Either way, kind of makes me sad. But Louie comes there, he looks around and is like, oh, this is a good place to do. do homework on other things. I'm like, great. It looks like he pays Michael what appears to be $5 for this essay. For this essay. I looked up what a motorcycle costs in 1961. Okay. On the low end, $800. I mean, he gets a pretty junkie motorcycle that he has to fix up through a series of montages. He goes to like basically a junkyard. Yeah. So if he got one that's $800, it'd be about 160 essays.
我不知道。无论哪种方式，都让我有点难过。但路易来到那里，他环顾四周，就像，哦，这是一个做其他事情的家庭作业的好地方。我就像，太棒了。看起来他为这篇论文付给迈克尔大约5美元。为了这篇论文。我查了一下1961年摩托车的价格。好的。在低端，800美元。我的意思是，他得到了一辆相当破烂的摩托车，他必须通过一系列蒙太奇来修理它。他基本上去了垃圾场。是的。所以如果他得到一辆800美元的，那大约是160篇论文。
Oh my. There can't possibly be that many. There's only four T-birds. I know. I think you got a real piece of junk. I mean. Well, now we go to a biology lesson by Mr. Stewart. With Miss Mason in the room.
哦，天哪。不可能有那么多。只有四个雷鸟队员。我知道。我想你得到了一件真正的垃圾。我的意思是。嗯，现在我们去斯图尔特先生的生物课。梅森小姐也在房间里。
It's got the famous, where does the pollen go? Yes. This is the song Reproduction. Let's hear the beginning of it. Reproduction. Reproduction. Reproduction. I got your pistol right here.
它有著名的，花粉去哪了？是的。这是那首歌《繁殖》。让我们听听它的开头。繁殖。繁殖。繁殖。我这儿有你的手枪。
Back here. Don't you get in your seat. Yeah, there you go. You've got this whole number now. The boys are all on one side of the room. The girls are on the other side of the room. The girls are doing that sort of stereotypical back in the day sort of thing of being both like sort of sexy, but also the gatekeepers of sex. The boys are just like, you know, letcherists and wanting to get it on.
在这儿。别回到你的座位上。是的，就是这样。你现在有整个表演了。男孩们都在房间的一边。女孩们在房间的另一边。女孩们正在做那种老派的刻板印象，既像某种性感，又是性的守门人。男孩们就像，你知道，好色之徒，想要做那件事。
There is one moment, though, where the girls pretend to be the boys and the boys pretend to be the girls. The boys are like, oh, you always say now. And the girls are like, yeah, I do this. So I did appreciate that moment. We did have a little role reversal there. Yeah. Catchy song. My sister and I were too shy to sing this one.
不过，有一个时刻，女孩们假装是男孩，男孩们假装是女孩。男孩们就像，哦，你总是这么说。女孩们就像，是的，我确实这么做。所以我确实欣赏那个时刻。我们确实有一点角色互换。是的。朗朗上口的歌。我和我姐姐太害羞了，不敢唱这一首。
I get it. We wouldn't do this one. You didn't want to sing about the pollen tubes? I guess we didn't. But then, ironically, we would belt out. Let's do it for our country. which is coming up. Guess what, everybody?
我明白了。我们不会做这一首。你不想唱关于花粉管的歌吗？我想我们不想。但后来，讽刺的是，我们会大声唱出来。《让我们为我们的国家做这件事》。这即将到来。猜猜怎么着，大家？
Michael has enough money for a motorcycle. He fixes it up by reading a manual. This kid has got so many manuals. He's very smart. And he's going to practice writing it in the park. Frenchie looks on. She's concerned. At the end, he like pulls away, and then he looks over his shoulder at her.
迈克尔有足够的钱买摩托车了。他通过阅读手册把它修好了。这个孩子有很多手册。他非常聪明。他打算在公园里练习骑它。弗兰奇在看着。她很担心。最后，他像开车离开，然后他回头看了她一眼。
He's wearing like his mechanics jumpsuit. Oh, this, I was dead. Like, he is so cute. This is the look that got it for you? This is the one. This is the Maxwell Caulfield, posters going on my wall. This look. There's another one, too.
他穿着他的机械师连体裤。哦，这个，我死了。就像，他太可爱了。这就是让你心动的造型？就是这个。这就是麦克斯韦·考尔菲德，海报贴在我的墙上。这个造型。还有一个，也是。
Okay, mine comes later. It involves a turquoise sweater. Oh, I know it. There is now a montage, you guys, with a passage of time. You know, we find out everyone made the talent show because I guess they didn't have enough people sign up. We see people practicing for the talent show. We see Michael working on his bike, tinkering with his bike, trying to learn how to pop a wheelie, things like that. Yeah, the T-birds are really intimidated by the Mr. Sandman Trio.
好的，我的在后面。它涉及一件绿松石色的毛衣。哦，我知道它。现在有一个蒙太奇，你们，随着时间的流逝。你知道，我们发现每个人都参加了才艺表演，因为我想他们没有足够的人报名。我们看到人们在为才艺表演练习。我们看到迈克尔在修理他的自行车，摆弄他的自行车，试图学习如何翘头，诸如此类的事情。是的，雷鸟队真的被睡魔三人组吓到了。
The Sandman T-M trio are singing in the showers. They're harmonizing in the showers and the T-birds are worried. Are they really going to win the records? Yeah. These guys are good. Those guys are real good. Now the montage is over and we're back at the bowling alley. The rival gang, you guys, you know, the cycle.
睡魔三人组在淋浴间唱歌。他们在淋浴间和声，雷鸟队很担心。他们真的会赢得唱片吗？是的。这些家伙很棒。那些家伙真的很棒。现在蒙太奇结束了，我们回到了保龄球馆。敌对帮派，你们，你知道，自行车。
Lords. Yeah. They're going to surprise the T-birds. There's so many cycle lords. This is not an even match. Here's the thing. So just the leader is outside. And as Dolores walks in, she calls him scum and she runs in and tells the T-birds, he's outside and he's all alone. So then the T-birds go outside, but by the time they get there, the whole rival gang is there. All of the lords are there. How many are there of them? Yeah. But as you've mentioned, it's like 20 against four. They start to rough up Davy. Yeah. And then the mysterious writer appears.
领主。是的。他们要给雷鸟队一个惊喜。有太多的自行车领主了。这不是一场势均力敌的比赛。事情是这样的。所以只有领袖在外面。当多洛雷斯走进来时，她叫他渣滓，她跑进去告诉雷鸟队，他在外面，而且他一个人。所以雷鸟队出去了，但当他们到达时，整个敌对帮派都在那里。所有的领主都在那里。他们有多少人？是的。但正如你提到的，就像20对4。他们开始欺负戴维。是的。然后神秘的骑手出现了。
Yeah. All hell breaks loose. Yeah. There's this shot of everybody inside the clear bowling alley doors. Watching. I wrote down, I cannot even imagine the nightmare this shot was for continuity. Also, clearly, they had people like on. Rizers, yes.
是的。地狱爆发了。是的。有一个镜头是每个人都在透明的保龄球馆门内。看着。我记下来了，我甚至无法想象这个镜头对连续性来说是多么噩梦。而且，显然，他们有像在。立管上的人，是的。
Yeah. Because how were they so tall? They fill the whole thing. Cinematically, it's a really cool shot. It is. It took a lot of work, though. So they are watching out these glass doors as this single mysterious motorcycle guy takes on this whole gang. The whole gang.
是的。因为他们怎么那么高？他们填满了整个东西。从电影角度来看，这是一个非常酷的镜头。它是。不过这花了很多功夫。所以他们透过这些玻璃门看着这个神秘的摩托车手独自对抗整个帮派。整个帮派。
None of them can catch them. 20 versus 1. They can't get them. Also, they suddenly just can't ride their motorcycles. All he does is ride by and they fall over. They fall. I know. They're like, Amaget.
他们中没有一个人能抓住他。20对1。他们抓不住他。而且，他们突然就不能骑摩托车了。他所做的只是骑过去，他们就摔倒了。他们摔倒了。我知道。他们就像，阿马格特。
Now everyone spills out of the doors. they're all in the parking lot now. Well, wait, we have to talk about the song that's going on this whole time. Who's that guy? I know. Stephanie is instantly fascinated, clearly turned on by this mysterious writer. This starts what I'm calling acting with bubble gum portion of the movie. Oh, does she have a lot of bubble gum in this one?
现在每个人都从门里涌出来。他们现在都在停车场了。嗯，等等，我们必须谈谈这整个过程中播放的歌。那个人是谁？我知道。斯蒂芬妮立刻被迷住了，显然被这个神秘的骑手激起了兴趣。这开始了电影中我称之为“口香糖表演”的部分。哦，她在这部电影里有很多口香糖吗？
What? Are you crazy? She's popping big bubbles. She's pulling it out of her mouth and stringing it back. fourth. She's chomping on it nervous. Chomping on it nervous. She pops it, rolls her eyes. She pops it sexy. There's so much gum acting here. I do not notice it. Oh my gosh. My personal favorite part of this song is the part where Michael sings about himself in the third person. I thought we should hear it because this song is great. I also wrote down how you sing this song with zero irony.
什么？你疯了吗？她在吹大泡泡。她把它从嘴里拉出来，又拉回去。她在紧张地咀嚼它。紧张地咀嚼它。她吹破它，翻白眼。她性感地吹破它。这里有太多的口香糖表演。我没有注意到。天哪。这首歌我个人最喜欢的部分是迈克尔用第三人称唱自己的部分。我想我们应该听听，因为这首歌很棒。我还记下了你是如何毫无讽刺地唱这首歌的。
I don't know. What would they say if they knew it was Michael? That's him while he's taking on the gang. That's him. But he also sounds a little bit like Cartman from South Park. Like, dude, it's Michael. Oh, my God. It's really crazy.
我不知道。如果他们知道是迈克尔，他们会怎么说？那是他在对抗帮派时的样子。那是他。但他听起来也有点像《南方公园》里的卡特曼。就像，伙计，是迈克尔。哦，天哪。这真的很疯狂。
It's really crazy. Well, anyway, he does it. He defeats them. He does. And then we lead into us. scene that I love. Stephanie, she can't stop just staring off into space. And the pink ladies have to come over. And this is a scene called There's Been Talk. Wait. What? I love that scene, but before that happens, my favorite line, maybe in the movie, happens. What is it? Johnny is pissed off.
这真的很疯狂。嗯，无论如何，他做到了。他打败了他们。他做到了。然后我们进入了一个我喜欢的场景。斯蒂芬妮，她无法停止盯着虚空看。粉红女郎们不得不走过来。这是一个叫“有传言”的场景。等等。什么？我喜欢那个场景，但在那之前，我电影中最喜欢的台词可能发生了。那是什么？约翰尼很生气。
Mysterious writer has messed with his mojo. And he goes, everyone inside, we bowl. It's so good. All right, well, now let's hear There's been talk. You know, Steph, there's been talk. We haven't been talking. But there has been talk, Steph, questioning your loyalty to the birds.
神秘的骑手搞乱了他的魅力。他说，大家进去，我们打保龄球。太棒了。好吧，现在让我们听听“有传言”。你知道，斯蒂芬，有传言。我们没有在谈论。但确实有传言，斯蒂芬，质疑你对雷鸟队的忠诚。
Well, it doesn't mean that you gotta go steady with Johnny. In fact, I think it's better for the both of you that it's over. Yeah, but the code does say that we're cheap. At least till grand. Let's go, Lewis. Yeah, well, maybe I'm tired of being someone's chick. Tired at being someone's chick. Are you feeling okay?
嗯，这并不意味着你必须和约翰尼稳定下来。事实上，我认为这对你们俩来说结束了更好。是的，但准则确实说我们很便宜。至少直到盛大。我们走吧，刘易斯。是的，嗯，也许我厌倦了做某人的小妞。厌倦了做某人的小妞。你感觉还好吗？
I don't know what I'm feeling. Here, have a siggy. Maybe it'll make you feel better. Yeah, I love it. I love all that dialogue. I think it's great. Have a siggy. Have a siggy.
我不知道我在感觉什么。来，抽根烟。也许它会让你感觉好点。是的，我喜欢它。我喜欢所有的台词。我觉得太棒了。抽根烟。抽根烟。
Paulette offers her a siggy, but she can't get it lit. She can't. But guess who can light it? The cool rider. He offers her a ride. She can't believe it. But then the cops show
波莱特递给她一根烟，但她点不着。她点不着。但猜猜谁能点着？酷骑士。他主动提出载她一程。她不敢相信。但后来警察出现了
up and he says, some other time. And then he jumps the entire cop car. Yeah. Stephanie's about to come undone. I think we do need to discuss the mysterious writer's wardrobe. It is no shirt. Yes, it's no shirt under, but with a leather jacket. Leather jacket, very unzipped, though, like halfway down to his belly button to show off his chest. When he offers to light her cigarette, you can see his breath. So I know it was cold that night. But yeah, mysterious writer. Yeah. Johnny sees all of this, by the way, and he is really upset.
他说，改天吧。然后他跳过了整辆警车。是的。斯蒂芬妮快要崩溃了。我想我们确实需要讨论神秘骑手的服装。它是没穿衬衫。是的，没穿衬衫，但配了一件皮夹克。皮夹克，虽然拉链没拉，拉到肚脐眼一半，露出他的胸膛。当他主动提出点燃她的香烟时，你可以看到他的呼吸。所以我知道那天晚上很冷。但是的，神秘骑手。是的。顺便说一句，约翰尼看到了这一切，他真的很生气。
Yeah, there's this weird shot of him at the end taking it all in. Also, we should note he is doing an American accent. When he's the mysterious writer. When he offers her a ride. Yeah. All right, well, it's the next day. Michael is hanging out with Frenchie in the science lab. Oh, she's heard all about it.
是的，最后有一个奇怪的镜头是他把这一切都看在眼里。此外，我们应该注意到他正在说美国口音。当他是神秘骑手时。当他主动提出载她一程时。是的。好吧，那是第二天。迈克尔在科学实验室和弗兰奇闲逛。哦，她已经听说了一切。
Oh, yeah. He's like it was me. Yeah. And she's like, you knocked her socks off as the cool writer. But when you're yourself, you knock her socks back on. Oh, that's a great line. I know. Well, the pink ladies walk in. Michael claims that he's got confidence from the night before. He's going to ask her out as Michael.
哦，是的。他就像那是我的。是的。她说，作为酷骑士，你让她大吃一惊。但当你做你自己时，你让她又穿上了袜子。哦，那是一句很棒的台词。我知道。嗯，粉红女郎们走进来。迈克尔声称他从前一天晚上获得了信心。他打算以迈克尔的身份约她出去。
Yeah. So he's going to go and he's going to have this sexy lead-off question. He's like, hey, you ever read a Superman comic? And she says, not in the last few hours. This is your go-to leadoff line? Mm-hmm. You've ever read a Superman comic? Michael.
是的。所以他打算去，他会有一个性感的开场白。他就像，嘿，你看过超人漫画吗？她说，过去几个小时没看过。这是你的开场白？嗯哼。你看过超人漫画吗？迈克尔。
Yeah. Michael. So listen, you're not going to see Frenchie again. She's done. Oh, that's right. You're not going to see her at the end of the movie. She just sort of disappears now. And in a 2003 interview, D.D. Con explained that the reason Frenchie disappears halfway through the movie is because the script was not finished when they began filming.
是的。迈克尔。所以听着，你不会再见到弗兰奇了。她完了。哦，对了。你不会在电影结尾见到她了。她现在就那样消失了。在2003年的一次采访中，D.D.康解释说，弗兰奇在电影中途消失的原因是他们开始拍摄时剧本没有完成。
The draft they started with included Frenchie, but the character was written out. She was told halfway through the movie that she was no longer needed. They did decide to include Frenchie in the final cut, but they had very limited footage. She described the entire filming process as rushed, frantic, and unorganized. Yeah. So anyway, that's the end of Frenchie. Well, now Louie is going to sneak into Michael's uncle's nuclear fallout shelter to try to trick Sharon into sleeping with him. Yeah, he has the other T-birds go outside the shelter and crank, like, the alarm.
他们开始时的草稿包括弗兰奇，但这个角色被写掉了。她在电影中途被告知她不再需要了。他们确实决定在最终剪辑中包括弗兰奇，但他们只有非常有限的镜头。她形容整个拍摄过程是匆忙、疯狂和无组织的。是的。所以无论如何，这就是弗兰奇的结局。嗯，现在路易要溜进迈克尔叔叔的核辐射避难所，试图欺骗莎伦和他发生关系。是的，他让其他雷鸟队员去避难所外面，转动，就像，警报。
The siren. Yeah. Yeah. Mm-hmm. They're going to have this duet called Let's Do It for Our Country. Yeah. You can imagine what that entails. Yes.
警笛。是的。是的。嗯哼。他们要进行这个叫“让我们为我们的国家做这件事”的二重唱。是的。你可以想象那意味着什么。是的。
She's going to get wise to him at the end, and she's like, I'm out of here. She's upset. But there's this whole thing where she's, like, wrapping him up in gauze and stuff. She thinks she's healing his. Like Florence Nightingale or something? Before he goes off to war. Mm-hmm. I guess she's going to wrap him in some gauze.
她最后会对他变聪明，她说，我离开这里。她很生气。但有一整件事是她，就像，用纱布把他包起来之类的。她认为她在治愈他的。就像南丁格尔之类的？在他去打仗之前。嗯哼。我想她打算用一些纱布把他包起来。
and then have sex with him. I don't know. I'm not sure. All right. You know. Well, now we're at the gas station. Yes, the only mechanic in this whole movie is Stephanie. It's her dad's gas station.
然后和他发生关系。我不知道。我不确定。好吧。你知道。嗯，现在我们在加油站。是的，整部电影中唯一的机械师是斯蒂芬妮。这是她爸爸的加油站。
Because in Greece, you know, the greasers are mechanics. Mm-hmm. So Stephanie is that for this movie. Well, she's very overwhelmed. She has multiple people asking her for things. They're very annoyed patrons at this gas station. Yes. I don't understand why she doesn't.
因为在《油脂》里，你知道，润滑油工是机械师。嗯哼。所以斯蒂芬妮就是这部电影的那个。嗯，她非常不知所措。她有很多人要求她做事情。在这个加油站有非常烦人的顾客。是的。我不明白为什么她不。
finish one thing at a time. She starts three different customers things. Like, just finish it and then move to the next person. But instead, she's got three unfinished businesses all yelling at her. All yelling at her. Gas is, I would like to point out, 50 cents a gallon. Michael pulls up, he puts some gas in his motorcycle. He says, what do I owe you? Yeah. Zizai has to be very quiet, Husky. He is a little bit of Batman. Yeah. What do I owe you? She says, 50 cents. Yeah. He's wearing his leather jacket. It's unzipped. Still no shirt. underneath. Amazing. And then she realizes who it is.
一次完成一件事。她开始了三个不同顾客的事情。就像，完成它，然后转到下一个人。但相反，她有三件未完成的生意都在对她大喊大叫。都在对她大喊大叫。我想指出，汽油是每加仑50美分。迈克尔开车过来，他在摩托车里加了一些油。他说，我欠你多少钱？是的。齐扎伊必须非常安静，沙哑。他有一点蝙蝠侠的感觉。是的。我欠你多少钱？她说，50美分。是的。他穿着他的皮夹克。拉链没拉。下面还是没穿衬衫。太棒了。然后她意识到是谁了。
It's the cool rider. And they are going to go for this bike ride. I mean, Stephanie is living her best life. Yeah, they ride away on the bike. She's wearing no helmet. No helmet. Her hair also looks fine by the end of it. She hasn't eaten a bug.
是酷骑士。他们要骑自行车去。我的意思是，斯蒂芬妮正在过她最好的生活。是的，他们骑着自行车离开了。她没戴头盔。没戴头盔。她的头发到最后看起来也很好。她没吃虫子。
Her eyes aren't watery. And her hair looks normal. You're right. Also, though, in the middle of them going down the road, she moves and straddles him from the front. Yeah, she does like a little leg wrap around. Yeah. They stop at sunset at the top of the hill.
她的眼睛没有流泪。她的头发看起来很正常。你是对的。不过，在他们沿着路走的时候，她移动并从前面跨坐在他身上。是的，她做了一个小腿环绕。是的。他们在山顶的日落时分停下来。
They are kissing. He's never taken off his helmet or his goggles. Nope. This whole time. Pretty sure his goggles have fogged up. And he's about to reveal his identity. And then they're interrupted by the arrival of the entire T-Bird gang. Yeah.
他们在接吻。他从来没有摘下他的头盔或护目镜。没有。整个过程中。很确定他的护目镜已经起雾了。他正要揭露他的身份。然后他们被整个雷鸟帮派的到来打断了。是的。
And he races away. He says, I'll see you Friday, night at the talent show. And she's like, what talent show? How do you know? Yeah. Yeah. So this is pretty steamy this moment between them, right? Like they have some chemistry, like you're seeing them together. Would you be surprised to know that according to the internet, Michelle Pfeiffer and Maxwell Coughfield did not get along during filming? Oh, I read that it was platonic. I didn't know it was. Yeah, maybe it doesn't get along is the wrong wording. But a few years after the film was released, Maxwell said in an interview that they got along infamously. And Michelle Fiver
他飞快地跑开了。他说，周五晚上在才艺表演见。她说，什么才艺表演？你怎么知道？是的。是的。所以这一刻在他们之间非常热烈，对吧？就像他们有一些化学反应，就像你看到他们在一起一样。如果你知道根据互联网，米歇尔·菲佛和麦克斯韦·考尔菲德在拍摄期间相处得不好，你会感到惊讶吗？哦，我读到它是柏拉图式的。我不知道它是。是的，也许相处得不好是错误的措辞。但在电影上映几年后，麦克斯韦在一次采访中说他们相处得臭名昭著。而米歇尔·菲佛
supposedly in an interview said that she found Maxwell self-adoring. So, you know, this just goes to show you. You don't have to have chemistry in real life to have sparks fly on screen. Acting! Acting! Well, here's the thing, guys. Johnny is super upset by Stephanie's new romance. He threatens to fight the mysterious writer. Stephanie's like, stay out of my life. Now, Paulette is pissed because she's like, Johnny, you don't ever get jealous about me. Everyone tells Sharon to shut up. So all the ladies leave in a huff.
据称在一次采访中说，她发现麦克斯韦自恋。所以，你知道，这只是向你展示。你不需要在现实生活中拥有化学反应才能在银幕上擦出火花。表演！表演！嗯，事情是这样的，伙计们。约翰尼对斯蒂芬妮的新恋情非常生气。他威胁要打神秘的骑手。斯蒂芬妮就像，离我的生活远点。现在，波莱特很生气，因为她就像，约翰尼，你从来不对我嫉妒。每个人都告诉莎伦闭嘴。所以所有的女士们都气冲冲地离开了。
They all storm inside the gas station. That's right. Slam the door. I have a wardrobe tidbit about this scene. Yes. First of all, I did not discuss this up top. I should have all the pink ladies have a look. Sharon is Jackie Kennedy.
她们都冲进加油站。那是对的。砰地关上门。关于这一幕，我有一个服装花絮。是的。首先，我没有在上面讨论这个。我应该所有的粉红女郎都有一个造型。莎伦是杰基·肯尼迪。
That's why she wears the little pillbox hat and pearls. Stephanie is usually in all black. You know, she's the motorcycle kind of gal. She's got the necklace. Allison wears headbands and scarves. Paulette's character wants to be Marilyn Monroe. I mean, that's clear. Yes.
这就是为什么她戴着小药盒帽和珍珠。斯蒂芬妮通常全身穿黑。你知道，她是摩托车那种女孩。她有项链。艾莉森戴着发带和围巾。波莱特的角色想成为玛丽莲·梦露。我的意思是，这很清楚。是的。
And in this scene, she is dressed almost identical to Marilyn in the white dress that even flies up as she walks into the gas station. But here's what actress Lorna Left had to say about trying to get this Marilyn look. The whole thing with me was they wanted this character to start. sort of be this character who was obsessed with Marilyn Monroe. So it was all about my hair. And Alan wanted me to be literally the platinum blonde. And he sent me to a hairdresser in Westwood. And she bleached out my hair. And I got to tell you, It was really painful.
在这一幕中，她的装扮几乎和玛丽莲在《七年之痒》里的白裙造型一模一样，甚至在她走进加油站时裙摆还会飞起来。但关于如何打造这个玛丽莲造型，演员洛娜·莱夫（Lorna Left）是这么说的：“对我来说，他们希望这个角色一开始就表现出对玛丽莲·梦露的痴迷。所以重点全在我的头发上。艾伦（Alan）希望我真的是那种白金色的金发。他把我送到韦斯特伍德的一家理发店，他们把我的头发漂白了。我得告诉你，这真的很痛苦。”
And because in those days, they didn't have the real bleach now that they have that isn't painful. They bleached out my hair. I was weeping. And the next day, I went into hair and makeup for a hair and makeup test for the film. And the hairdresser went like this, and it came out in her hand. They had broken off all my hair. My hair was this long. And that's when Alan said, oh, put a wig on her.
因为在那个年代，他们还没有现在这种不伤头发的漂白剂。他们把我的头发漂白了，我当时都哭了。第二天，我去参加电影的妆发测试，理发师就这样一抓，头发就掉在她手里了。他们把我的头发全弄断了。我原本的头发有这么长。就在那时，艾伦说：“哦，给她戴个假发吧。”
I thought to myself, they couldn't have thought about that before they did that to me. So Alan that she's talking to is Alan Carr. He was a producer on the movie. And when you watch the interview, she sort of does the motion of what the hair person did. Yeah. It was just run her fingers through her hair. And it just came out in clumps. I mean, that's because, like she said, it was like, they just, like, scalded your hair.
我心想，他们在对我做这些之前就不能先考虑一下吗？她提到的艾伦是艾伦·卡尔（Alan Carr），他是这部电影的制片人。当你观看采访时，她还模仿了那个理发师的动作。是的，就是用手指梳过头发，头发就成团地掉下来。我的意思是，就像她说的那样，感觉就像他们把头发烫坏了一样。
Yeah. Back then. She said her hair ended up being like about an inch in length. It broke off that much. Wow. Yeah. Oh. So shout out to Lorna Left for enduring all that.
是的，那时候。她说她的头发最后只剩下大约一英寸长。断了那么多。哇。噢。所以要向忍受了这一切的洛娜·莱夫致敬。
She's so good in the movie. She's so great. I love her as Paulette. I do too. Well, with all the girls inside the gas station, the T-Birds, they decide that they need some guaranteed action. Yeah, they're going to go prowling. Yeah.
她在电影里演得真好。她太棒了。我喜欢她演的波莱特（Paulette）。我也喜欢。好吧，加油站里的女孩们，也就是“雷鸟”帮（T-Birds），她们决定需要一些“保证能得分”的行动。是的，她们要去“狩猎”了。是的。
They launch into. the go-and-prowling song, which kind of turns into a rehearsal for their talent show performance. Yeah, it like morphs into it. And I will say the number they perform, I guess, for the talent show, stylistically is really cool-looking. There's like this back, thin curtain on the stage. Yeah. And the gals, I guess where you go to score is the grocery store? Yeah, because it's like three ladies' shadows and their cats. Ash years at a grocery store and they're dancing. Yeah, it's this cool kind of black and white effect behind them.
她们开始唱起“狩猎之歌”，这首歌后来变成她们才艺表演的排练。是的，它演变成了排练。我得说，她们为才艺表演准备的那个节目，从风格上来看真的很酷。舞台后面有那种薄薄的幕布。是的。而且，我猜你们去“得分”的地方是杂货店？是的，因为那是三个女士的影子和她们的猫。她们在杂货店里跳舞。是的，她们身后有一种很酷的黑白效果。
Yeah. And now we know their talent show number. Right. All right. Well, now we're back in Miss Mason's class. She's now teaching English. Mm-hmm. And Stephanie has to stay after class because she didn't do well on her Shakespeare essay.
是的。现在我们知道她们的才艺表演节目了。没错。好了，现在我们回到梅森小姐的课堂。她现在在教英语。嗯哼。斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）必须留堂，因为她的莎士比亚论文写得不好。
Right. Guess who's going to help her, you guys? It's Michael. Yeah. They have a very cute scene at like this little coffee shop. where he's going to help her with her homework. And there's chemistry there where he's just Michael. There is chemistry.
没错。你们猜谁要去帮她？是迈克尔（Michael）。是的。他们在一家小咖啡馆里有一场非常可爱的戏，他要帮她做作业。他们之间有化学反应，他就是迈克尔。确实有化学反应。
Yes, this scene is meant to show that Michael and Stephanie can have a connection even when he's not the cool writer. Right. But here's my beef with it. I don't understand how after spending a significant amount of time with Stephanie, Michael isn't totally turned off by her. She seems completely superficial and self-absorbed. She just keeps talking to him about the cool writer.
是的，这一幕是为了表现迈克尔和斯蒂芬妮即使在他不是“酷骑士”的时候也能产生联系。没错。但这就是我不满的地方。我不明白为什么在和斯蒂芬妮相处了这么久之后，迈克尔竟然没有完全被她劝退。她看起来完全肤浅又自恋。她一直在跟他谈论那个“酷骑士”。
She says, what if he takes off his goggles? And he's just like an ordinary guy. And he's like, what if he is? And then she's like, I don't want to talk about this anymore. And then like she's obsessed with the ketchup. And like everything about her is like a giant turnoff to me. And she kind of eats a hamburger like the Carl's Jr. commercial.
她说：“如果他摘下护目镜，只是个普通人怎么办？”他回答说：“如果他就是呢？”然后她说：“我不想再谈这个了。”然后她还对番茄酱着迷。她的一切对我来说都非常倒胃口。而且她吃汉堡的样子就像卡乐星（Carl's Jr.）的广告一样。
I love how she eats the hamburger. What? It's so gross. No, I like it because she's not being fussy about it. She's going to dive right into that burger. and the fries, but I don't know. I mean, he's just like an intelligent person, and I feel like he's dumbing himself down for her, which always bums me out when people do in movies. I don't know. I think my thing with him is that he has to figure out how to be something he's not to win her over.
我喜欢她吃汉堡的样子。什么？太恶心了。不，我喜欢，因为她吃的时候一点也不做作。她直接大口吃汉堡和薯条，但我不知道。我的意思是，他是一个聪明人，我觉得他在为了她而装傻，每当电影里有人这么做时，我总是感到很沮丧。我不知道。我觉得我对他不满的地方在于，他为了赢得她的芳心，不得不把自己变成一个他根本不是的人。
Yes. And that's what you don't want to do. You want to be your authentic self. Right. And have someone love you just as you are. Well, she is impressed by him. By his smarts. Yes. But then he downplays it. He's like, oh, I'm no smarter than you. I don't understand the stuff anymore than you do. I just know a few big words that impress teachers.
是的。这正是你不该做的。你应该做真实的自己。没错。让别人爱你本来的样子。好吧，她确实对他印象深刻。被他的聪明才智所吸引。是的。但随后他却贬低自己。他说：“哦，我并不比你聪明。我懂的东西并不比你多。我只是知道几个能让老师印象深刻的大词而已。”
It's like, no, Michael, I think you understand it. I think you actually understand Hamlet. I think you do. Well, he's going to ask her out again. And she's like, no, you know, pink lady code, blah, blah, blah. And he's like, according to Dolores, the code stinks. Yeah. Johnny and Goose show up.
就像是，不，迈克尔，我觉得你懂。我觉得你其实懂《哈姆雷特》。我觉得你懂。好吧，他又要约她出去了。她说：“不，你知道的，粉红女郎（Pink Lady）的准则，巴拉巴拉之类的。”他说：“根据多洛雷斯的说法，这准则烂透了。”是的。约翰尼（Johnny）和古斯（Goose）出现了。
Johnny sees Michael talking to Stephanie. Once again, he's super ticked off. And lady, I think maybe Michael Scott had watched Greece too. Why? I think you've got to hear this. What do you want, Johnny? Yeah, well, I just want to let you know that I'm officially declaring us as an item officially over. You're declaring. That's correct.
约翰尼看到迈克尔在和斯蒂芬妮说话。他又一次超级生气。天哪，我觉得迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）可能也看过《油脂2》。为什么？我觉得你得听听这个。你想要什么，约翰尼？是的，好吧，我只是想让你知道，我正式宣布我们俩的关系彻底结束了。你宣布？没错。
Okay, fine. Okay? You declared it. It's over. Can I go now? He declared it. I declared bankruptcy. That's all I could think about in that scene.
好吧，行。行了吧？你宣布了。结束了。我现在可以走了吗？他宣布了。我宣布破产了。那一幕我满脑子想的都是这个。
Well, he asked her for her pink lady's jacket. Yeah. He's like, I have a rep to protect. If you're not going to date me, you're out of the pink ladies. If you're not going to date me while I date you and Paulette, you're out. Well, she doesn't give him his jacket. And do you see where she goes? Do you see where she walks to?
好吧，他向她要她的粉红女郎夹克。是的。他说：“我有名声要维护。如果你不跟我约会，你就被踢出粉红女郎了。如果你不跟我约会，而我却在和你还有波莱特约会，你就出局了。”好吧，她没有把夹克给他。你们看到她去哪了吗？你们看到她走到哪了吗？
The pink lady car. Whose car is it? Now she's driving it. I know. Now she's getting in the car. I don't get it. It cuts to Michael who's standing watching all of this by his motorcycle, by the cool rider's motorcycle.
粉红女郎的车。那是谁的车？现在她在开那辆车。我知道。现在她上车了。我不明白。镜头切到迈克尔，他站在摩托车旁看着这一切，站在“酷骑士”的摩托车旁。
No one notices that he's standing next to the motorcycle with the red flames on it. What is with the vehicles in this film? Anyway. Oh, God. Now the part of the movie that I fast forward through. It's the super long. It's the only part. It's the only part I don't watch. Let me tell you why you shouldn't fast forward. Why? There is no one hotter in a turquoise sweater than Maxwell Caulfield.
没人注意到他站在那辆有红色火焰图案的摩托车旁边吗？这部电影里的交通工具到底是怎么回事？总之。噢，天哪。现在到了我快进的电影片段。这是超长的一段。这是唯一的一段。这是我唯一不看的部分。让我告诉你为什么你不该快进。为什么？没有谁比麦克斯韦·考尔菲德（Maxwell Caulfield）穿绿松石色毛衣更帅了。
He is so dreamy in this sweater. I swear to God, they're selling it right now at Marine Layer. It's like a timeless sweater. He looks so cute. The song is long and boring. It's called My Sharrade. Yeah. It's him in the cafeteria. It's all different like moments in high school where he's just tired of playing this charade. Half the time he's not singing. He's just walking and looking around. I know. And the song is like a voiceover? It's all odd. Yes. But now it's the night of the talent show. Stephanie's waiting out front in her sparkly jacket. Cool rider shows up. But uh-huh. But uh-oh, the T-birds show up too. So he rides away. Why? Why does he keep riding away from the T-birds? He took on 20 of the cycle lords outside the bowling alley.
他穿这件毛衣简直太梦幻了。我发誓，Marine Layer现在就在卖同款。这真是一件永恒的毛衣。他看起来太可爱了。这首歌又长又无聊。叫《My Charade》。是的。这是他在食堂的戏。这是高中里各种不同的时刻，他只是厌倦了玩这种“猜谜游戏”。有一半时间他根本没在唱。他只是走来走去，四处张望。我知道。而且这首歌像是画外音？这太奇怪了。是的。但现在是才艺表演之夜了。斯蒂芬妮穿着闪亮的夹克在前面等着。酷骑士出现了。但是，呃哦，雷鸟帮也出现了。所以他骑车走了。为什么？他为什么要一直躲着雷鸟帮？他在保龄球馆外可是单挑了20个“摩托党”（Cycle Lords）。
four people. But apparently he can't take on these four guys on the motorcycle. So he speeds away and the T-birds chase him and then the girls follow them in the pink car. And guess what? There's a construction site. It conceals the deadly drop of dead man's curve. And he just goes flying off into the night. Can I say what I wrote? Yeah. He died? I thought where does the movie go from here? You really thought he died? How do you come back from that? I thought he'd. I died. Well, that's good. That's what they wanted you to think.
四个人。但显然他搞不定这四个骑摩托车的家伙。所以他加速逃跑，雷鸟帮追他，然后女孩们开着粉红色的车跟在后面。你们猜怎么着？有个建筑工地。它掩盖了“死人弯”的致命落差。他直接飞进了夜色中。我可以说说我写了什么吗？可以。他死了？我当时想，电影接下来要怎么演？你真的以为他死了？那种情况下怎么可能活下来？我以为他……我死了。好吧，那很好。那就是他们想让你以为的。
Stephanie's convinced, but I do have to go back because this is one of me and my sister's favorite lines from the movie. Oh, please, please. I'm sorry, say it. Say it. It's in the car when the pink ladies are chasing toward the construction site before he flies off the edge. And Sharon has a line because they're zipping around. And she goes. And Sharon is who you would be in the movie.
斯蒂芬妮深信不疑，但我必须回过头来说，因为这是我和我姐姐最喜欢的电影台词之一。噢，拜托，拜托。抱歉，说出来。说出来。是在车里，当粉红女郎们追向建筑工地，在他飞出边缘之前。莎伦（Sharon）有一句台词，因为她们在飞速行驶。她说……而莎伦就是你在电影里会成为的那种人。
This is me. This is my line. She says, we're going to die. And I'm wearing my mother's underwear. Sharon's line. I bet you guys love that. We love that line. We would always say that line when it came up.
这就是我。这是我的台词。她说：“我们要死了，而且我穿的是我妈的内衣。”莎伦的台词。我敢打赌你们肯定喜欢那句。我们喜欢那句台词。每当演到那儿，我们总是会说那句台词。
All right. So it's time for the talent show. I have this moment highlighted as my favorite Paulette moment because she finally lets Johnny have it. Yeah, Johnny thinks Paulette is dressed too skimpy. Johnny's not wrong. I'm sorry, for a high school student, is this what you wear, during the talent show. She's in...
好了，才艺表演开始了。我把这一刻标记为我最喜欢的波莱特时刻，因为她终于让约翰尼尝到了苦头。是的，约翰尼觉得波莱特穿得太暴露了。约翰尼没说错。抱歉，对于一个高中生来说，这就是你在才艺表演时穿的衣服吗？她穿着……
Lausierre. Is it like a boostier unitard? It's a boostier. She's got on... What do you call those? What do you call that thing? You put around your leg that you throw a wedding.
紧身胸衣。是那种胸衣连体衣吗？是胸衣。她戴着……你管那个叫什么？你套在腿上，婚礼上会扔的那个东西。
A garter. I mean, she's covered, but it's very suggestive. Yeah. And I just want to... There's nothing wrong with it except that I think she's 17. I know what it looks like.
吊袜带。我的意思是，她遮住了，但非常引人遐想。是的。我只是想……这没什么错，除了我觉得她才17岁。我知道它看起来是什么样。
What? Visually for people who haven't seen the movie, if you made a Playboy Bunny outfit, but like into like more of a corset look. Yeah. Right? Mm-hmm. Okay.
什么？对于没看过电影的人来说，视觉上，如果你做了一套花花公子兔女郎装，但把它做成了更像紧身胸衣的样子。是的，对吧？嗯哼。好吧。
It's like a one piece. Jordan's not a yet. Bating suit. Strapless. Mm-hmm. But lacy and suggestive. Yes. It's like what I wore in Blades of Glory.
就像一件连体衣。不是泳衣。无肩带。嗯哼。但蕾丝边，很诱人。是的。就像我在《荣誉之刃》（Blades of Glory）里穿的那样。
Oh, yes, it is. That's exactly what it is. Now people are going to Google that lady. Well, do it. I look great. You looked great. I just have to say what Paulette says to him, though. Yeah, I love it.
噢，没错，就是那样。现在人们要去谷歌搜索那位女士了。好吧，去搜吧。我看起来很棒。你看起来很棒。但我必须说出波莱特对他说了什么。是的，我喜欢。
She's like, maybe you can bully some chicks in this school, but this chick has been bully for the last time. I may not be the classiest chick, but I'm the best you're going to get. So take it or leave it. Yeah. And she's kind of swatting at him the whole time. Mm-hmm. He backs down.
她说：“也许你能欺负学校里的一些女生，但这个女生受够了你的欺负。我可能不是最优雅的女生，但我是你能得到的最好的。所以要么接受，要么滚蛋。”是的。而且她全程都在拍打他。嗯哼。他退缩了。
I was like, way to go, Paulette. But first, we're going to see the T-Birds sabotage the Mr. Sandman trio. Yeah. They tie them up. And, like, turn the showers on them or something. Yes. And then the T-birds go out, and they do a great job. They're a big hit.
我当时想，干得好，波莱特。但首先，我们要看雷鸟帮破坏“睡魔先生”（Mr. Sandman）三重唱。是的。他们把他们绑起来，然后打开淋浴喷头之类的。是的。然后雷鸟帮上台，他们表现得很好，大获成功。
They crush it. They crush it. Everyone loves them. Yeah. Then we have the pink ladies number, the Girl for All Seasons. Yeah. Amazing costumes, by the way. There's so many costumes, you guys, because they do all the seasons.
他们太棒了。他们太棒了。每个人都喜欢他们。是的。然后是粉红女郎的节目，《Girl for All Seasons》。是的。顺便说一句，服装太惊艳了。你们知道吗，服装太多了，因为她们表演了所有季节。
I'm just going to highlight three. Okay. December is Stephanie in a Christmas tree-themed dress is pretty amazing. She is wearing a star on top of her head. Yes. And she looks like a Christmas tree. January, it's a champagne glass featuring foam legs sticking out of the top. Yeah.
我只挑三个重点说。好的。十二月是斯蒂芬妮穿着圣诞树主题的裙子，非常惊艳。她头顶戴着一颗星星。是的。她看起来就像一棵圣诞树。一月，是一个香槟杯，上面有泡沫状的腿伸出来。是的。
combined with the red sparkly dress. It's amazing. February has to be in the top three. It's a wiggling George Washington face on a belly. She's a coin for President's Day in February. I did not. You know what? I thought she was Mount Rushmore. No, she's a coin. But what's interesting is that her body is painted to be the face of the coin. And the eyes of George Washington, are her boobs. And then she's like belly dancing, which makes his face move. And again, I just want to say, is this appropriate for high school? George Washington's eyes on a girl's boobs? I don't think it is.
搭配红色的闪亮裙子。太棒了。二月必须排进前三。她肚子上有一个扭动的乔治·华盛顿的脸。她是二月总统日的硬币。我没看出来。你知道吗？我以为她是拉什莫尔山。不，她是硬币。但有趣的是，她的身体被涂成了硬币的脸。而乔治·华盛顿的眼睛，是她的胸部。然后她在那跳肚皮舞，这让他的脸在动。我再次想说，这适合高中生吗？乔治·华盛顿的眼睛在女生的胸部上？我觉得不合适。
I'm going to say no. I did not put those two together. I didn't realize his eyes were her boobs because I was so confused by why Mount Rushmore was being featured in February. Okay. Well, they go through all the seasons. When Stephanie comes out and she starts to sing, she... Hallucinates?
我会说不合适。我没把这两者联系起来。我没意识到他的眼睛是她的胸部，因为我很困惑为什么二月要以拉什莫尔山为主题。好吧。总之，她们演完了所有季节。当斯蒂芬妮出来开始唱歌时，她……产生幻觉了？
Yeah, she kind of zones out the star that's on top of her head. She takes it down into her hands and then it flies out of her hand. And then she, like, follows it to, like, la-la land. She's, like, in a dreamlike fantasy. Yes. And now we do have a sort of thing that I think is meant to represent heaven or something because Michael is now on top of a mountain of white motorcycles. I wrote, is he an angel?
是的，她有点神游了，头顶上的那颗星星。她把它拿下来放在手里，然后它从她手里飞走了。然后她就像跟着它去了“梦幻岛”。她就像在梦幻般的幻想中。是的。现在我们有了一个我认为代表天堂之类的东西，因为迈克尔现在站在一座白色摩托车山上。我写道：他是天使吗？
This is what I wrote. Stephanie is now dressed as a Grecian goddess. Yep. She looks amazing. Yep. Michael's in all silver. This might be the weirdest number in the whole movie. There's a pile of old busted motorcycles that look white and dusty.
这是我写的。斯蒂芬妮现在打扮成希腊女神。没错。她看起来太美了。没错。迈克尔全身银色。这可能是整部电影里最奇怪的节目。有一堆破旧的摩托车，看起来又白又脏。
Are they like corpses? I don't know what they are. It's foggy. Oh, yeah, there's tons of fog. And I do have to note, again, that even in his silver motorcycle outfit, he has no shirt on under the jacket and zip down to his belly button. Yeah. This is a very long dream sequence song. It's a duet.
它们是尸体吗？我不知道它们是什么。雾蒙蒙的。噢，是的，雾气很大。我必须再次指出，即使在他那身银色的摩托车装束里，他夹克里面也没穿衬衫，拉链拉到了肚脐。是的。这是一首非常长的梦境序列歌曲。这是一首二重唱。
It's a duet. And Stephanie has two outfits. Yes. She's either Grecian goddess or she is also like in a silver jacket on the motorcycle with him. Yes. I wrote, don't know how you sing these weird. lyrics and not break, they are somehow 100% stone cold serious through this whole song, especially this part where there's a dialogue break.
这是一首二重唱。斯蒂芬妮有两套服装。是的。她要么是希腊女神，要么就是和他一起穿着银色夹克骑在摩托车上。是的。我写道：不知道你是怎么唱出这些奇怪的歌词而不笑场的，她们在整首歌里竟然百分之百一本正经，尤其是对话间隙的那部分。
And they talk to each other. Yeah, I have it. They do song talking. I have it. Oh, great. Here it is. Stephanie, please don't cry. It all seems so unfair.
他们互相交谈。是的，我有记录。他们用唱的方式对话。我有记录。噢，太棒了。在这儿。斯蒂芬妮，请别哭。这一切看起来太不公平了。
Just when I found you, I lost you. That doesn't matter, no. The only thing that matters is that I love you. And you're the only one who can keep our love alive. So Stephanie, don't forget me. I promise. Yeah, so. Then it morphs back into her being in the talent show.
刚找到你，就失去了你。那不重要，不。唯一重要的是我爱你。你是唯一能让我们的爱延续下去的人。所以斯蒂芬妮，别忘了我。我保证。是的，所以。然后它又变回了她在才艺表演的场景。
Yes, and she's singing this weird solo now that has nothing to do with calendar girls. She's singing, turn back, uh-oh, all by herself. The crowd is mesmerized. Yes. You could hear a pin drop. She's sad. She's on her knees. The song ends, and the audience erupts into a standing ovation.
是的，她现在唱着这首奇怪的独唱，和“日历女孩”毫无关系。她唱着《Turn Back》，呃哦，独自一人。观众被迷住了。是的。针掉在地上都能听见。她很伤心。她跪在地上。歌曲结束，观众起立鼓掌。
Ovation. And then Johnny and Stephanie win the talent show. They win the talent show, which I didn't realize meant that they were crowned king and queen of a luau. Which is coming up. It's an all, I wrote at this point, what is happening? What is happening? Now we have a rockahoola luau. Yes, this is clearly the we go together of Greece, too.
鼓掌。然后约翰尼和斯蒂芬妮赢得了才艺表演。他们赢得了才艺表演，我没意识到这意味着他们被加冕为卢奥派对（Luau）的国王和王后。这马上就要到了。我当时写道，发生了什么？发生了什么？现在我们有了“摇滚呼啦”卢奥派对。是的，这显然是《油脂2》里的“We Go Together”。
This is, you know what this number is? We don't know where the script is going. Let's get everyone back in one big scene together. Dance it out. I wrote, there are so many continuity errors in this low-wile scene. I don't even know how to start. Well, I want to talk about how everybody is dressed so festively except for Stephanie, who's still mourning the death of Cool Rider, she shows up in a slouchy gray sweatshirt
你们知道这是什么节目吗？我们不知道剧本要往哪走。让我们把所有人都召集到一个大场景里。跳舞吧。我写道：在这个卢奥派对场景里有太多的连贯性错误。我甚至不知道从哪说起。好吧，我想谈谈每个人都穿得那么喜庆，除了斯蒂芬妮，她还在为“酷骑士”的死哀悼，她穿着一件松垮的灰色运动衫。
and jeans. She's over it. She's not happy. She's done. But yeah, there's a big dance number. Big, big dance number. And then there's a big, like above ground swimming pool in the middle of this luau. My aunt Louise and Uncle Sonny had one.
和牛仔裤。她受够了。她不开心。她完了。但确实，有一段大型舞蹈。非常大型的舞蹈。然后卢奥派对中间有一个大型的地上游泳池。我路易丝阿姨和桑尼叔叔家有一个。
I don't know how they put so many things in it. Well, it starts with Mr. Stewart and Miss Mason. They're in a boat in the middle. People are swimming and dancing in the water, but then suddenly they're not in the water. And you never see them again. In the water, out of the water. No one's drying off. There's no towels.
我不知道他们怎么往里面塞了那么多东西。好吧，从斯图尔特先生和梅森小姐开始。他们在中间的一条船上。人们在水里游泳和跳舞，但突然间他们就不在水里了。你再也没见过他们。在水里，出水面。没人擦干。没有毛巾。
Yes. We dance until the sun sets. and now it's time for the king and queen to take their positions. They're in some kind of native dress. It doesn't feel appropriate. Yeah. They have crowns. They're in a bamboo raft with paddles.
是的。我们跳舞直到日落，现在是国王和王后就位的时候了。他们穿着某种民族服装。感觉不太合适。是的。他们戴着皇冠。他们在竹筏上，拿着桨。
Yes. And they're put in the above-ground pool. By, by, like, six high school guys who are dressed in loincloths. Yeah. Did you see the guy on the right? Is it the same guy that ran track? I don't know. I hope not because clearly they didn't heat this water.
是的。他们被放进了那个地上游泳池。被六个穿着缠腰布的高中男生。是的。你看到右边那个家伙了吗？是那个跑田径的家伙吗？我不知道。我希望不是，因为显然他们没给这水加热。
Because when this guy hits the water, he visibly like flinches. Like you see like the wind come out of him. He's like, it's so cold. It's so cold. Johnny is smoking. He's always smoking. He drops his cigarette. He almost catches the raft on fire.
因为当这个家伙碰到水时，他明显地畏缩了。就像你看到他倒吸一口凉气。他就像是，太冷了。太冷了。约翰尼在抽烟。他一直在抽烟。他掉了烟头。他差点把竹筏点着了。
Yeah. The bamboo raft. He and Stephanie are bickering. She's in such a sour mood. and now wouldn't you know it? Wouldn't you know it? The cycle lord show up. Can we, there's one thing I've been wanting to say.
是的。竹筏。他和斯蒂芬妮在争吵。她心情很糟糕。现在你们猜怎么着？你们猜怎么着？摩托党出现了。我们可以……有一件事我一直想说。
What is it? One thing. There's one thing. What is it? Just go with me on this. Let's say you're madly in love with a guy. Okay. Who plummets to his death off a, like a cliff on a motorcycle.
什么事？一件事。有一件事。什么事？跟我一起想。假设你疯狂地爱上了一个男人。好的。他骑着摩托车从悬崖上坠落身亡。
Yeah. And then you immediately go to your talent show. Yeah. What? That's why she couldn't get through the number, Anne. Why did she even go? go. I don't know. And now she's like on a pontoon boat and an above ground. That's why she's so grumpy. Okay. That's why she's so annoyed. Okay. Anyway, cycle lords show up.
是的。然后你立刻去参加你的才艺表演。是的。什么？这就是为什么她没法完成表演，安。她为什么要参加？我不知道。现在她又在浮桥船上，又在地上游泳池里。这就是她为什么那么暴躁。好的。这就是她为什么那么烦躁。好的。总之，摩托党出现了。
Yes, and they're running over all the decorations. It's crazy. People, there's like a cake booth, and they're going to throw cakes at the cycle lords, but they end up throwing cakes at each other. Yeah. People are throwing stuffed animals at them. Stephanie and Johnny, they're trying to row the raft out of the pool, but they can't seem to row. It's not working. Don't worry. Don't worry. Because during the mayhem, the mysterious writer shows up.
是的，他们碾过了所有的装饰品。太疯狂了。人们，有个蛋糕摊，他们要向摩托党扔蛋糕，但最后他们互相扔蛋糕。是的。人们向他们扔毛绒玩具。斯蒂芬妮和约翰尼，他们试图把竹筏划出游泳池，但他们划不动。没用。别担心。别担心。因为在混乱中，神秘骑士出现了。
He shows up. He is on top of a thatched roof. Very high. Yeah. Very high. He jumps off of it, legs split, and lands on what we guess is his motorcycle, because the next shot is him just riding away. How his nuts survive that.
他出现了。他在茅草屋顶上。非常高。是的。非常高。他跳了下来，双腿劈开，落在他猜是他的摩托车上，因为下一个镜头就是他骑车走了。他的蛋蛋是怎么在那次跳跃中幸存的。
I don't know. I don't know. Here's how he's going to save the day. He jumps over the pool of water. Jumps over, Stephanie. Yeah. And Johnny. Yeah.
我不知道。我不知道。这就是他拯救世界的方式。他跳过了游泳池。跳过了斯蒂芬妮。是的。还有约翰尼。是的。
He makes it all the way across. So that means that all the cycle lords have to do the same jump. But they can't do it and they all land in the water. But they don't land on Stephanie and Johnny. No. Because they're no longer in the pool. I guess they got out. Oh my gosh.
他成功跳了过去。这意味着所有的摩托党都必须做同样的跳跃。但他们做不到，全都掉进了水里。但他们没掉在斯蒂芬妮和约翰尼身上。不。因为他们已经不在游泳池里了。我猜他们出去了。天哪。
Lady, there's so much chatter online about it. People are like, okay, during the Luel, people appear to disappear and appear on the boat and appear and disappear and disappear. into the pool. Some people fall in, then they're not there. It's like a whole thing. Also, someone else pointed out, when the bike flips into the pool, the cord that they use to make the bike flip is completely visible. Oh. So there's that. I see. Well, I guess he did it. He saved the day. It's really nuts. The cycle lords could have ridden around the pool, but maybe not. I guess that's the challenge. That's how it works when you are cycle fighting. It's like, can you do the stunt or not?
天哪，网上关于这个的讨论太多了。人们说，好吧，在卢奥派对期间，人们似乎消失了，又出现在船上，又消失，又出现在游泳池里。有些人掉进去，然后就不见了。这简直是一团糟。还有人指出，当摩托车翻进游泳池时，他们用来让摩托车翻转的绳子完全清晰可见。噢。原来如此。好吧，我想他做到了。他拯救了世界。这真的很疯狂。摩托党本可以绕过游泳池，但也许不行。我猜这就是挑战。这就是摩托车战斗时的运作方式。就像是，你能不能完成这个特技？
Yeah. Stephanie's so excited. She's like, oh, my God, you're alive. She takes off her crazy outfit they had her wear, and under it is not her sweatshirt. Yeah, now she has a cute outfit on. A silver lamay, amazing shimmery dress slash Unitar. Michael, guys, now has a leather vest, collar up. No shirt, obvi. And at first, you guys, Johnny sees all of this, and he is so pissed off. And he runs. He's up to him. And then he's like, you got one more jump. And she's like, Johnny, hasn't there been enough? And then the T-birds are like, yeah, hasn't there been enough, Johnny? Hasn't there been enough?
是的。斯蒂芬妮太兴奋了。她说：“噢，天哪，你还活着。”她脱掉了他们让她穿的那套疯狂的衣服，下面不是她的运动衫。是的，现在她穿了一套可爱的衣服。银色金属感，惊艳的闪亮裙子连体衣。迈克尔，伙计们，现在穿了一件皮背心，领子立着。没穿衬衫，显而易见。起初，伙计们，约翰尼看到了这一切，他气坏了。他跑向他。然后他说：“你还有最后一跳。”她说：“约翰尼，难道还不够吗？”然后雷鸟帮说：“是啊，难道还不够吗，约翰尼？难道还不够吗？”
And then he's like, jacket. And then he's like, Jacket. And then Paulette's like, jacket. And then he gets the jacket. And then he gives it to Michael. And he's made Michael a T-bird. And now he and Stephanie, they can be together. They can.
然后他说：“夹克。”然后他说：“夹克。”然后波莱特说：“夹克。”然后他拿到了夹克。然后他把它给了迈克尔。他让迈克尔成了雷鸟帮的一员。现在他和斯蒂芬妮可以在一起了。他们可以了。
And there's going to be a lot of coupled them. The final song is called We'll Be Together. Everyone is dancing, and this song wins closest singing in each other's faces award. Yeah, there's a lot of spinning, singing into each other's faces. But I'm talking like maybe... Lip to lip. Like two fingers. Put two fingers up to your lips. Yep.
会有很多情侣。最后一首歌叫《We'll Be Together》。每个人都在跳舞，这首歌赢得了“脸贴脸唱歌”奖。是的，有很多旋转，对着对方的脸唱歌。但我说的是可能……嘴唇对嘴唇。就像两根手指。把两根手指放在嘴唇上。没错。
And then imagine someone else's face on the other side of your finger. Singing at you. Singing, full voice. I have an audio clip. It has a little bit of dialogue between. Stephanie and Michael, and then it leads into the top of this song. I never thought you'd kiss me like that if you knew what I really was. Are you crazy?
然后想象另一个人的脸在你的手指另一边。对着你唱。大声唱。我有一个音频片段。它有一点斯蒂芬妮和迈克尔之间的对话，然后引出这首歌的开头。我从没想过如果你知道我的真实身份，你还会那样吻我。你疯了吗？
I'm a two for the price of one. You certain? I've never been certainer. No, son. The certainest. The certainest. Yeah, I like that. I'd love to kiss you again.
我是买一送二。你确定吗？我从未如此确定过。不，孩子。最确定。最确定。是的，我喜欢那个。我很想再吻你一次。
Yeah. I would have suggested. that they cut that dialogue before the singing? Because again, Michael, what are you seeing in her? This is the woman for you? Lady, I love this movie so much now, and I am the certainest of it. I hear you. I hear you. You know what? He accepts her where she is. That's right. That's the love. He's like, I love you. You dumb, dumb. Did I please kiss you again?
是的。我会建议他们在唱歌前剪掉那段对话？因为再说一次，迈克尔，你在她身上看到了什么？这就是你的真命天女？天哪，我现在太喜欢这部电影了，而且我对此最确定。我听到了。我听到了。你知道吗？他接受了她本来的样子。没错。这就是爱。他说：“我爱你，你这个小笨蛋。我可以再吻你一次吗？”
Maybe he's like, don't speak. Don't speak. Could we go back to the kissing? I love you so much when we're kissing. And she's like, you don't need to talk to me. Just let me ride on your motorcycle. Maybe this is a relationship in silence. Well, this whole thing is going to morph into graduation.
也许他说的是：“别说话。别说话。我们能回到接吻吗？”我太喜欢我们接吻的时候了。她说：“你不需要跟我说话。只要让我骑你的摩托车就行。”也许这是一段沉默的关系。好吧，这一切都要演变成毕业典礼了。
Now we're back outside Rideau High. Everyone's in caps and gowns in front of the school. They're throwing their caps in the air. Everyone's singing toward the camera, except for Stephanie and Michael, who are still singing right into each other's faces. And then we're going to have this final montage that I've always loved. It starts with the whole group of people running toward the camera. They jump in the air and it's like a freeze frame.
现在我们回到里多高中（Rideau High）外面。每个人都穿着毕业袍，戴着学士帽在学校前面。他们把帽子扔向空中。每个人都对着镜头唱歌，除了斯蒂芬妮和迈克尔，他们还在对着对方的脸唱歌。然后我们要看这个我一直很喜欢的最终蒙太奇。它从整群人跑向镜头开始。他们跳向空中，就像定格画面一样。
And that sort of like becomes like a yearbook picture. Yeah. And then you see everybody kind of coupled up in their couple pairs and they run toward the camera kind of in slow motion and they do some sort of fun jump and it freezes. And that's part of the yearbook. Yes. There were two alternate endings for this movie. Would you like to hear them? I can't wait. Okay. So one alternate ending had Michael and Stephanie flying off into the sky on a motorcycle, which would have mirrored Danny and Sandy flying off in the car at the end of Greece. They didn't do that.
那就像毕业纪念册的照片。是的。然后你看到每个人都成双成对地跑向镜头，慢动作，做一些有趣的跳跃，然后定格。那是纪念册的一部分。是的。这部电影有两个备选结局。你们想听吗？我等不及了。好的。一个备选结局是迈克尔和斯蒂芬妮骑着摩托车飞向天空，这会呼应《油脂》结尾丹尼和桑迪开车飞走的情节。他们没那么做。
But also, Patricia Birch proposed an idea to feature John Travolta and Olivia Newton-John reprising their characters as a now-married couple running a gas station at the end of the movie, and it would have even involved John Travolta singing a new number called Gas Pump Jockey. But this did not come to fruition. So I guess there was the option to end the movie with a little cameo. So I guess they would have ridden their motorcycle together. to Danny and Sandy's gas station. Yeah.
而且，帕特里夏·伯奇（Patricia Birch）提议让约翰·特拉沃尔塔（John Travolta）和奥莉维亚·纽顿-约翰（Olivia Newton-John）回归，饰演他们现在的已婚角色，在电影结尾经营一家加油站，甚至还会涉及约翰·特拉沃尔塔唱一首叫《加油泵骑师》（Gas Pump Jockey）的新歌。但这没有实现。所以我猜本来可以选择以一个小客串结束电影。所以我猜他们会一起骑摩托车。去丹尼和桑迪的加油站。是的。
And there would have been this little reunion. I guess with a whole song. How does gas pump jockey go? I don't know. Speaking of songs, so you watched this movie for the first time. Last week. Yes. Aren't the songs so catchy?
会有这样一个小团聚。我猜还有一整首歌。加油泵骑师怎么唱？我不知道。说到歌，你第一次看这部电影。上周。是的。这些歌不是很洗脑吗？
You know these songs are good because you hear them once and you can sing, I want to score tonight. You can sing, let's do it for our country. You know these songs after one time watching the movie. Driving in here today, I was singing, I'm going to go tonight. Exactly. It's great.
你知道这些歌很好，因为你听一遍就能唱出“I want to score tonight”。你能唱“Let's do it for our country”。你看一遍电影就知道这些歌了。今天开车过来的时候，我还在唱“I'm going to go tonight”。没错。太棒了。
Yeah. That's a great musical. That is a really fun musical. And really, Greece, too, has everything. It's got Russia. It's got fallout shelters. It's got lots of cigarettes, lots of gum, gum, and stiff, collared shirts. Yeah. You guys, I highly recommend it. And I also want to say thank you today.
是的。那是一部很棒的音乐剧。那真是一部很有趣的音乐剧。真的，《油脂2》什么都有。有俄罗斯。有防空洞。有很多香烟，很多口香糖，还有硬领衬衫。是的。伙计们，我强烈推荐它。我也想今天说声谢谢。
In the booth, we have Jordan filling in for Sam. Thank you, Jordan. You're welcome. I was so excited to be helping with this episode because I grew up avidly watching Greece, too. How many times have you seen it? Oh, many times. I had a vinyl of it growing up because my parents, they graduated in 72. I literally, my dad rode a motorcycle and worked on them his entire life. I have pictures of him doing wheelies and next to, like, motorcycles. Your dad was a cool writer, Jordan. He was a Thunderbird. He was a Thunderbird.
在录音室里，我们有乔丹（Jordan）代替萨姆（Sam）。谢谢你，乔丹。不客气。我很高兴能参与这一集，因为我从小就是《油脂2》的忠实粉丝。你看过多少次？噢，很多次。我从小就有它的黑胶唱片，因为我父母是72年毕业的。我爸爸真的骑摩托车，而且他一生都在修理摩托车。我有他做翘头动作和在摩托车旁的照片。你爸爸是个酷骑士，乔丹。他是雷鸟帮。他是雷鸟帮。
And Matt is here all the way from San Francisco. Matt, thanks for being here today. This was great. This was very fun to watch. My sister and I are Greece purists, so we never really delved into this. So this was interesting to watch. I had a good time. Well, I want to say a thank you to Nathan for suggesting this movie.
马特（Matt）从旧金山远道而来。马特，谢谢你今天能来。这太棒了。看这部电影很有趣。我和我姐姐是《油脂》的纯粹主义者，所以我们从未真正深入研究过这部。所以看这个很有意思。我玩得很开心。好吧，我要感谢内森（Nathan）推荐这部电影。
Mm-hmm. Hit us up, guys. Let us know what do you want us to watch because we like watching stuff together. We really do. I couldn't have predicted half of the plot lines for Greece 2. It was a real adventure. And I hope you guys all score tonight, whatever that means to you. We love you and we'll see you next week.
嗯哼。联系我们吧，伙计们。告诉我们你们想让我们看什么，因为我们喜欢一起看东西。我们真的喜欢。我无法预测《油脂2》的一半情节。这真是一次冒险。希望你们今晚都能“得分”，无论这对你们意味着什么。我们爱你们，下周见。
Delight, I love doing it. Me too. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了，我喜欢做这个。我也是。感谢收听《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由詹妮弗（Jennifer）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle），音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。